i'm at my friend tim poole's house
oh it's very very fine
i'm at my phantom pools house so it's
very very fine
[Music]
i'm here to sell my book it's speechless
controlling words controlling minds
[Applause]
[Music]
so this guy michael knowles shows up to
my house and he notices a guitar in the
corner
and he was like what's all that i was
like hey go play it and then uh
just like literally 30 seconds before
about to go live he writes that and i
was like wait wait let's open with that
have you played that song
uh so there's news today big news
outside of
speechless by uh michael knowles your
book john mcafee man
poor guy epstein he you think so yeah
there's no i think the conspiracy theory
is that john mcafee killed himself in
prison right that's the that is the
least plausible
we'll we'll definitely i want to i want
to save it because we're going to this
will be big so we'll just do quick
intros but the long story short is
mcafee has repeatedly said he would
never take his own life
they are now reporting he apparently did
he was about to be extradited back to
the u.s where he said they were going to
get him
they were claiming he had crypto hidden
and owed tax dollars he wasn't paying
and now this now they're saying they
found him dead and it's apparent suicide
but we're going to go through the tweets
the things he's posted and the actual
conspiracy theory
plus some other news we got uh what is
it general mark milley saying that white
rage caused january 6. yikes and joe
biden is going after guns again
he's going to be diverting what is it
350 billion dollars from covid funding
into going after guns or something like
i mean this is this is nuts but
i want to make sure i get the facts
right so so we'll we'll get to those
stories but
as you may have already noticed michael
nols is hanging out he actually opened
the show with song
how's it going man it's going great i'm
so exhausted
because this is book week so the
speechless came out yesterday
and they just send you on this tour and
you just you're talking i've been
showing this thing for six months but
now this is the week to do it so i'm
really glad we could get a little music
going
trying to loosen up a little plus i
think we've already done enough shilling
for your book personally on this show
i haven't yet though if i hit the best
seller list
it is because of you it is this show
that's right because everybody was super
chatting something like this latest news
story has left me speechless
just like speechless by michael knowles
like yup yup it was
it was one of the smartest marketing
campaigns mind you i you know it was a
brilliant marketing campaign that i
never thought of
i guess uh you guys put together like a
montage of me
getting caught by the super chats and
being like oh they got me you know like
but uh so yeah yeah we'll definitely
we'll talk about all that as well um
we've got ian chef hey everybody ian
crossland what's up michael i'm so glad
your book's out now dude
i want to hear all about it tonight i'm
excited i'm done i'm done
you know i am loving tim cass the
musical
i would like to make this a normal thing
uh michael's uh skill is very much
appreciated i'm excited for tonight
yeah i was impressed that was a good
song
on top of your head uh right on you know
these days
i i'm really branching out you know i
think this is what nancy pelosi sold
obamacare she said
you can just explore your arts you can
be a poet you can be a musician so
that's what i'm doing boom there you go
perfect all right well we gotta get to
these stories but before we do ladies
and gentlemen we have an amazing sponsor
it's virtual shield the virtual private
network
service for you go to
surfinginternetsafe.com the link is in
the description below
and you can get 30 off for life they say
3.49 per month now
a virtual private network service what
this does is very very easy you download
program
you click go and you can actually set it
so that you appear to be in like any
other country what this does is
makes it harder for hackers for
governments for spies for nasty nosey
individuals
to spy upon your data makes it harder
for big tech it is a basic level of
security
it's like closing your blinds locking
your window you know i i always explain
it like this you may have heard it a
million times but i'm eternally grateful
to
virtual shield for sponsoring the show
for so long we don't always expect
people to break into our houses but we
still lock our doors we still lock our
windows that's why it really does make
sense have some basic level of security
especially if you know you may be
connecting to
certain networks that are not your home
or something you always want to have
some basic protection
virtual shield offers you this and they
actually say that right now you can get
24 months of the online security from
the world's easiest and fastest vpn for
only 83.83
that's actually 68 off plus you'll get
30 of
all add-ons and other great discounts
from their other plans
they're proud to announce that this
month all discounts are guaranteed for
life that means 30 percent off for as
long as you are a customer
go to surfing internet safe the link is
in the description below and i'm going
to shout them out just
look virtual shield my first sponsor
ever
on any youtube thing i ever did they
have been there from the beginning and
i'm eternally grateful to any one of
these companies that wants to sponsor
shows like this because it shows they
really care
and they're willing to do what so many
others aren't i'm eternally grateful for
that thank you virtual shield but don't
forget
you can also go to timcast.com become a
member we're gonna have a bonus segment
coming up
at around 11 or so and of course many of
you may be may now know that cassandra
fairbanks is officially coming on as the
editor-in-chief she's writing articles
for us they're amazing
her work is is absolutely brilliant
we've got a handful of other journalists
who are set to join very soon
the new website is launching very soon
we just hired our paranormal and
unexplained writer
who's going to be working on a series of
articles that it's like
news stories that we never quite
understand these are real
these are not you know creepy it's not
meant to be
like supernatural in the sense that we
believe in magic
but it's more so these are crazy stories
that have never been explained that we
want to explore
plus we're gonna do a lot more we got
the vlog as you know and i will just
shout out now
we're actually uh hiring a few roles
we're looking for a video uh
filmer and editor as well as a building
manager
and a receptionist so jobs at
timcast.com become a member
let's jump into this first story the one
that no one believes but is being
reported anyway
wall street journal says john mcafee
anti-virus software creator is found
dead in spanish jail notice the headline
they used
many other networks are saying from
apparent suicide or was found dead due
to suicide
not the wall street journal they say
he's just found dead spanish court had
ordered his extradition to the u.s
where he faced tax-related criminal
charges they say
the manhattan u.s attorney's office also
sought the extradition of mr uh mr
mcafee in a separate criminal case john
was and will always be remembered as a
fighter
said nichei casanon an attorney
representing mr mcafee in u.s criminal
proceedings
he tried to love this country but the
u.s government made his existence
impossible
now i'm going to jump over to this
article from cassandra fairbanks over at
timcast.com
because she actually breaks down what
makes this story so interesting
in cassandra's article she notes several
tweets from mcafee himself
he tweeted once getting subtle messages
from us officials
saying in effect we're coming for you
mcafee we're going to kill yourself
i got a tattoo today just in case if i
suicide myself i didn't i was whacked
check my right arm and he has a tattoo
on his right arm that says
it's a dollar sign and whacked there's a
she also mentions a year before that
tweet he claimed if i hang myself allah
epstein it will be no fault of mine
the accenture eccentric figure was
arrested by spanish authorities october
3rd 2020
at the l pratt airport at the behest of
the us government he was wanted for
evading paying millions of dollars in
taxes
he was facing 30 years in prison here's
another tweet from john mcafee who said
powerful people who commit crimes have
only one enemy those who reveal crimes
and it's a photo of julian assange
there's another photo for another tweet
from mcafee where he said i have nothing
yet i regret nothing
the u.s believes i've hidden crypto i
wish i did but it has dissolved through
the many hands of team mcafee
he says uh and my remaining assets have
all been seized my friends evaporated
through fear of association
so this is what makes the story so
interesting which
which is the more plausible conspiracy
because no matter what you choose to
believe it's a conspiracy
right did mcafee kill himself well
that's a conspiracy someone killed him
right who did it why yeah
it's they're saying it was a suicide or
did he
did or i should say if he did kill
himself that means
everything he tweeted was an elaborate
plot to manipulate people in the event
he actually did
or whatever maybe change his mind and if
he didn't actually do it then who
actually killed the guy
so i i'm just going to say this people
are saying he got epsteined
that's the verb they're using which
makes the assumption
that uh what people think about epstein
you know we all know that story
in this in this instance i'm just gonna
say it mcafee repeatedly said he would
never kill himself
that means you would have to believe he
set up an elaborate plot
to manipulate everybody in the event he
actually did
because not only are they saying it is
suicide when he said he wouldn't do it
but after he died we get this mike
rothschild says john mcafee's final
instagram post
a giant queue the post went up around 1
15 pacific time
meaning he was likely already dead but
he or someone else on his team
knew exactly what to do to achieve
maximum ish posting effect
okay so what is it what's going on
you know what this tells you that this
tells you forget about mcafee for a
second very
sad that he died forget about whatever
happened in spain
or whatever the crimes are this tells
you what people think
about their own government right now the
fact that we use epstein as a verb
tells you what people think about their
own government if this were an earlier
era
say 100 years ago some guy is found dead
of suicide
the idea that the federal government
would have killed him would be very
outlandish to americans
i i actually don't think they would have
had such distrust in their government
that they would accept that i don't know
you think they always would have you
know one one of the issues i have to
deal with is
like a youth bias right so
i grew up kind of you know bright-eyed
bushy-tailed believing in america
i i had a family that still taught me
about
like not just the well let's call it the
colonial perspective
not a woke family by any means but you
know very um
analytical one and uh i believe in this
country
and then i think back to like when i see
all these political conflicts
i'm like this is the worst it's ever
been and then i'm like but i've heard
about the weather underground
yeah so i wonder if it really is the
worst it's ever been or just the worst
i've ever seen
in which case you think about you know
certain civil rights figures who were
killed yeah martin luther king i mean
there's a conspiracy he actually a civil
suit was settled with his family i think
it was in 2001.
that the fbi yeah some responsibilities
i think the fbi or ca but somebody was
like involved with his death and his
family got paid out by the government
i don't know a whole lot about it so i i
don't want to wait too much into
conspiratorial territory but wasn't
there like a letter sent to him by some
fed telling him to kill himself or
something like that i don't know
well you know it's certainly the case
that the federal government was keeping
tabs on him
as they were on many other radical
figures and in
in most of these cases by the way the
simplest explanation
is usually the the one that i'll go with
so in the killing of kennedy there are a
million theories on how kennedy was
killed
the communists wanted to kill him a
communist said that he killed him
and then we were told that a communist
killed him and he was an anti-communist
so i
got to go with it you know i kind of
believe it in this case though
we have seen every single american
such corruption from the federal
agencies in just the last five years
the the federal agencies being turned on
a political opponent during the 2016
race
to try to subvert that election then
they continued to go after trump after
he was in office
then the complete dishonesty that we've
gotten from the federal government
and the international community during
kovid during the lockdowns changing the
story every day
that this is a real political problem
when we just when we assume
that the federal government is just
popping people off in prison
and and we just shrug our shoulders
what's going to happen with the mcafee
story
nothing nothing what happened with the
epstein story nothing
we laughed about it we turned it into a
meme that to me that is more distressing
actually than any of these discrete
incidents
we're in that dystopia yeah we and and
nothing's being done
to to get justice the system is
completely broken there's that story
right now of this
this grandma who got a misdemeanor
charge for the insurrection
which really does send a you know a
sledgehammer to the narrative
oh some little old lady got a
misdemeanor slap on the wrist for what
you call an insurrection
come on they couldn't even get these
people but but you look at still the
lopsided prosecution of this
where in new york it was just reported
by the new york post
hundreds of charges related to looting
and rioting were dropped the majority of
charges in the bronx
and in manhattan the majority of them
completely dismissed and then the other
ones by the way
where people are looting where people
are robbing pled down to trespassing
which carries no jail time it's very
very simple
charge january 6th that was an
insurrection
well you know rotten solitary if you put
on the horn helmet and you go dance on
nancy pelosi's lectern
that is a crime against humanity for
which you you need to go to gitmo
obviously the the double standard is
preposterous you think of this little
old granny
from the the capital riot if she had
just thrown a molotov cocktail at a
courthouse in minneapolis
she'd get off scot-free but there's
there's obviously a massive double
standard here to be fair though
the ones they go after are actually the
ones who target the government building
so like in the instance of portland
most of the ones most of these rioters
and looters who smash up small
businesses
and punch cops hey no problem but but
the ones who actually set fire to the
police building yeah
they're getting charged because that's
that that's that's that's the way it
works you go after the government
they throw the book at you but the after
private citizens they don't care
what is that phrase we keep hearing with
january 6th
the cool resurrection you know
the phrase we we uh keep hearing is that
this is a threat
to our democracy our
and i'm reminded of this point by angelo
coteville he's a scholar at the
claremont institute
who points out that the people who talk
about
our democracy tend to be referring to
their oligarchy they don't seem to be
very democratic at all
john mccain started calling people
friends yeah a friend
in 2008 i think he was running for
president eight 2008 yeah
and he just kept saying friend and it
was like i'm not your friend
no one really is so cut it out yeah
i loved it so uh i was one of those
people that said you know sad to see
john mccain pass when he did
but like literally every political uh
like quadrant of the political spectrum
there was a meme where it was like
centrists were like you know i can
pay respects and death and the
authoritarian left libertarian left
libertarian right to throw attention
right we're all like he was awful and
evil and good written
yeah but but anyway going back to the
the mac everything i'm talking about
this this conspiracy
this post that goes up on his instagram
the big q what the heck what was john
mcafee wanted for
he wasn't some political figure yeah it
was tax evasion
so i have to i i'll say this i can
understand the idea that some people
might say
look the guy was a troll and so he knew
that doing everything he did would
create this conspiracy in his death and
that's what he was going for
john mcafee so i i stopped and i said
yeah he was a troll
he loved it he loved every minute of it
even being in prison he was
still posting yeah i don't think the guy
would want to end that
he he was old sure but the dude
loved doing these these these things
with the media with twitter with social
media
i just don't i don't i don't see it um
yeah i don't know the fact that we can't
name
what the crime was is is kind of weird
isn't it i mean don't you when someone
is invasion with taxes i guess it's tax
evasion there was some issue in latin
america
where someone was killed you remember
and there was this cl i don't know this
was years ago at this point i mean he's
had this i worked for advice i know all
of that's right you have a sort of
association to this story
he obviously the guy lived a colorful
life to say the very least
but the fact that this guy was being
held in a spanish prison
the u.s is trying to extradite him he's
a very well-known figure but
but all the details are kind of murky
and then he winds up dead after saying
he would never kill himself
that's like out of a out of a thriller
movie the challenge is this dude's life
was so fantastical
yeah that you have to wonder how much of
it was him being a storyteller
right so is this a guy who was old
no money left in prison and so he was
like
my last hurrah is going to be the best
troll ever
rather than get stuck in prison and just
rot away yeah he's an old old guy and he
was like i am going to pull off the
greatest troll in the history of mankind
he's he's on the verge of could be the
but the thing is
people who are actually brought to to do
that
to take their own life this is not some
flippant thing you know it's not just
just a joke on twitter i mean this is
yeah you're coming face to face with
your mortality
the people who tend to do that don't in
my experience and having
read about these things they don't seem
to be exuberant at the last moment you
know they
i don't know this would that would be
quite a show to put on as you're
doing this that's why ultimately i don't
believe it yeah the the dude was such
a a um bombastic character who enjoyed
every minute of it
i just don't see him being like this is
the end of the line for me you get weird
stories some people will like clean
their whole house
before they kill themselves and you're
like what the heck because they didn't
want to leave a mess
like it's just really weird psychology
going i don't know if he was just beaten
down in prison if he was being tortured
if he if he was under threat of like
torture and like gonna give up some
people that he actually did give his
money to that now he's just kind of lied
and killed himself to protect them
well one of the things he said in one of
his tweets earlier was that all the
bitcoin that he had a mess had kind of
disappeared to i think
tim mcafee which is kind of interesting
to me so he's already saying that he
doesn't have any money
so i don't know if you're going to die
and if you are an ish poster in life
then you might want to be one in death
as well i don't know what he was doing
you know like he he he would tweet a lot
about how he had he was gonna name names
he had evidence of stuff
right now here's here's the fun part
apparently he posted
that you know someone asked him i hope
you set up dead man switches that in the
event you
you are you know taken out or something
they'll get released and he says i have
and they will
and i'll name names and it'll all come
out that's why the the cue that was
posted on instagram has a lot of people
going like
is this it is it going to happen yeah
get ready somebody who knew him posted
it i'm not i'm not convinced
many millenarian cults around the world
have said on this date
this is when it will all change this is
the fight everything is going to be
different and it it just never is and
and whether it's with the election
whether it's with some
corruption in the federal government i
keep waiting for the date and it never
comes around epstein is trending
nationwide on twitter oh wow
that's that that's the part that really
creeps me out the most yeah that
you know what what are the guards in
that story they lied right that's what
that's
that's the news that came out yeah they
lied
something weird went down people fell
off his top bunk with a sheet tied
around his neck is that the story
yeah yeah i don't know man yeah but it's
not any sort of
dainty clinton-esque fingerprints on his
throat i don't know
it's weird i think he said the week
before he died someone was trying to
poison him and he looked
well his is his cellmate attacked him
yeah oh really yeah
and that's why people are calling it
getting epstein yeah
i do i do like the way he phrased it
though when he said the the feds were
saying i will kill yourself
that's one way to put it what he's doing
yeah but the
the really sad thing about this for me
obviously you feel bad for his family
and his friends
what are we going to do about it i mean
for even forget the mcafee thing for a
second
i guess i don't really feel bad for
epstein's friends that's one
limits of sympathy are only somebody
yeah yeah yeah what are we going to do
about it if we
are also i think probably the vast
majority of americans
believe that jeffrey epstein was offed
or
someone was permitted to off him or
there was some corruption involved
and yet uh and that's the way the
government works
i i gotta say i love it the the best
tweet out of the entire
was when the story broke was it was
chris raygun
who said he got into an uber and the
driver immediately turns and goes
yo that guy didn't kill himself like
this random uber driver said that
and look i honestly don't know it is it
is possible
i think we got to check our movie biases
right like here's the example i always
use people think silencers go pew pew
pew
like they don't they go whap really loud
yeah
um they're amazing by the way they do
you know you're outside and you're like
the first time i ever fight with
suppressor i was like wow
not like a movie though still
ridiculously loud and you can follow the
sound to go find your friends when
they're at the range or whatever
but because of the movies people
genuinely believe these things yeah so
when you see a story like epstein like
there really is a simple solution that
the dude was at the end of his rope like
and the same is true for mcafee the same
is true for epstein very literally at
the end of this road yeah i mean
look you can even think about it now
first of all i certainly think there's a
lot of malfeasance
corruption something weird happened with
epstein but it's not out of the realm of
possibility it's actually
very likely i wouldn't say i would
weight it as prob
the most probable yeah but here you got
a guy who was living large
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
from who knows where
doing whatever you want to do some
people think it was blackmail yeah they
got him
imagine if this guy's whole emma was
that he was filming
these elites in compromising positions
and then blackmailing them
yeah and they were scared that if they
went against them they he'd release
footage of them that's like one of the
conspiracy theories
now imagine he ends up in prison having
lost and he knows he's done
and you've got a lot of people wealthy
individuals who are sweating bullets
it may have just been that the elites he
was blackmailing should he have been
if he was i'm not saying he was he just
lost or at the very at the very least he
went from very very
here's what i said at the time i'm like
here's a guy who's got his own private
island
he was living the biggest life a human
could hope to live
and now he's in a prison cell it's
possible
i mean here's a person who just like
finally says okay and with mcafee the
same thing same thing
uh same thing here's a guy who's really
old he's had his adventures had his
journeys
for 30 years was he i actually didn't
think he was born in 45 yeah so
oh okay yeah he's older he's older than
i thought he was older 75.
still i mean it's not 95 you know right
but still
up there and maybe but maybe he was like
30 years in prison
i'm a gothic bang yeah yeah that's what
i think i don't know i think he just i
think he took him took his own life it's
tough to say
the thing is the government doesn't like
copycat criminals which is part of why
they're cracking down so hard on people
that are violating federal buildings and
federal property
and the reason why they go up for people
for tax evasion because if mcafee gets
away with millions of dollars tax
evasion
gets away with it right a lot i suppose
this is my problem with it though
of course people at the end of the rope
can off themselves and that's happened
plenty of times he's a pretty high value
individual he's a pretty high profile
prisoner jeffrey epstein was the most
high profile prisoner in the whole
system
how do you just get allowed to kill
yourself is it aren't there cameras i
don't have like a
you know i have like a ring doorbell i
would mel i forgot about that
and the two guards malfunctioned and
then lied about it right
yeah i mean when we used to put people
on suicide watch at the hospital
you would take everything from their
room you couldn't have a call light with
a cord
you couldn't have metal utensils to eat
with you got a paper tray
your food was on like a styrofoam thing
you had nothing you didn't have a phone
with a cable you didn't have
blinds with a cord you didn't have bed
sheets you literally didn't have bed
sheets so it shocks me on every level
that they allowed this to happen
especially since epstein had tried to
commit suicide this is why he was by
himself
let's uh let's do a bit of a hard segue
here because
you know we're i'm just thinking about
the corruption of the elites yeah the
ideology that permeates through them
and there's like there's only so much we
can't say necessarily about what
we're speculating on you know mcafee or
epstein but we have this other story
that i want to jump into
joint chiefs chairman mark milley
defends teaching critical race theory in
the military slams offensive claims that
troops are turning woke
and links white rage to the capital riot
now i know it's not the perfect segue
off of you know we were just talking
about but there is this core element of
what's happening to our political elites
our establishment our industry elites
the ideology they've embraced
and this story actually freaked me out
to see joint chief chairman
was he's a general mark milley saying
that he's reading mao zedong
and lenin but that doesn't make him a
communist
and that white rage was what caused
january 6 essentially it's offensive to
say what did they say
uh the general appeared to link white
rage to the capital right on january 6th
now that's one of the the most the
freakiest things i've seen i mean this
is
a non-theistic religion i guess you'd
call it a cult yeah
the highest levels of government can't
you just imagine the gunnery sergeant
did you just make a transphobic comment
soldier that is not my pronoun
yeah how dare you micro aggress sir i
thought i was supposed to macro
aggression
yeah right right i have a gun for that
reason but apparently
so i have to wonder about um these are
people who believe there is no truth but
power
they have routinely said there's no
objective reality and
the idea that there is no truth but
power is
i would say to a certain degree there's
an element of truth to it but it is a
very very fascistic ideology
that is being employed by the left when
i say there's a certain element of truth
basically that means
sure if a bunch of leftists have
weapons and are beating you and then
demand you say there are five lights
yeah you can force someone to say there
are five lights but but there won't
actually be
exactly right but the history books will
tell you that there were right and
that's what that's what the left has
realized
that they can beat people in submission
to just say
falsehoods on the under the and assert
it's true and then they're hoping that
in 10 years
these stories will become history right
well it's it's the left tells us they're
doing this with the 1619 project they
they say
outright this woman nicole hannah jones
lied about her central thesis
but she said yeah whatever i don't care
about the facts i'm
reframing american history to put
slavery at the center of it and it's
it's very effective to do that
and that's what they're doing now in the
navy this was the military was basically
the last
institution that the conservatives still
had some control over
all of the other ones the media the
schools the
administrative government all of that
had fallen a long time ago and now in
the military you're seeing that
that total infiltration that the chief
of naval operations came out
and he made what i felt was such a
disingenuous
argument to defend all this woke
nonsense in the in the reading list for
the
ensigns and the sailors he said we need
our sailors
to be critical thinkers and i think what
he really meant is we need our sailors
to be critical theorists
you do not if you want to be a good
effective military
you do not need to read ibram candy
the idea by the way that the military is
some open free marketplace of ideas
where
the military literally brainwashes you
that's like the point of military
training
and that but and now they're doing that
in marcusa
and now in all of the people actually
that i talk about in this book
speechless coincidentally
i mean that is the the infiltration that
we've seen in all our institutions
so now it's there and every moment that
they're reading kendy and mao
is a moment that they're not reading a
worthwhile writer
you're right the classics right or klaus
fitz or somebody yeah you know we had
bannon the other day and he said we're
winning
we're winning he said he was against all
the you know the violence the capital he
was in favor of the commission
investigating it get to the bottom of
how it happened
because the violence is bad he was like
come august 15th when these kids go back
to school
these moms in the suburbs are going to
explode when they see what's being
taught to these kids
and what they're mandating putting the
kids in the corner make them wear a mask
whatever it is
but i really do think imagine what
happens
when i mean first of all imagine this
you're uh you gotta
your kid just turned 18 wants to join
the navy he comes back to visit you
after basic training
and it's like so what'd you learn and
he's like i learned you're an evil
oppressor
white devil they're going to be like
what
basic training but you're supposed to
like be hardened and get in shape
people were so shocked when they or when
no it wasn't even the navy there were a
lot of jokes to make about the navy over
this
but it was but it wasn't the navy it was
the army came out with that ad
yes and they said you know it was that
cartoon of the young girl and she said i
became a strong soldier
because my lesbian moms took me to pride
parades as a kid you think
okay i don't know about that this is not
by accident when we can laugh about it
and say oh how funny the
the cia went woke cia has actually been
worked for a long time but the army went
woke
the purpose of this is to attract
leftist people
and to repel conservative people to
finish that infiltration of the
institutions and it
it's obviously working that is a very
dangerous thing because once that one
goes
we're out we're out of the culture
aren't we yeah this is
this is the first time i've really
thought of this is life and death um
for our species if if the not that the
american military is like the one is
like the great
protector there's a lot of we i have
pretty big united states bias obviously
i come from the us i've been taught
probably america the u.s probably
maintains the world pretty cruel though
and if it gets uh if it gets co-opted
not only did it lose a war but it's on
the side
of that which co-opted it so it's like
double your enemy
it is you know the the critical theory
of it all i know this is these terms get
thrown around now and now the left is
retreating into this nominalism of well
what really is critical theory what
really
but the theory is very simple the theory
is to criticize when whenever
some whenever some reporter tries to
have a gotcha what is critical race
theory what is it
very simply it's to to ruthlessly
criticize all that exists in the words
of marx
so that that's what they're doing and
the idea that we need
deconstruction in the military we need
destruction from the military but we
don't need
deconstruction within the military
that's a recipe for national death which
is probably what they want
i mean physical deconstruction of
foreign
military enemies with use of uh
ordinance
yes um philosophical deconstruction of
the
system in place which we use to defend
our country not so much but that's
what's happening but do you know
this i think brings up an important
point for conservatives or even
people who are just not woke who are
kind of normal
the reason they fail a lot of the time
is because they are
arguing in fantasy world american
government
so that when they make arguments about
american politics they're making
arguments about the three branches of
government
and the chuck's imbalances and the
separation and the thing that you
probably are no longer taught in civics
class but you used to be taught
the left is playing in the political
realities where
where are our laws made are they i am a
bill and i call myself you know you're
made on capitol hill and then you
no our bills are made by some faceless
nameless bureaucrat
in some gray building in washington dc
or even outside of washington dc
our laws are effectively made by
oligarchs in silicon valley
as mitch mcconnell pointed out the other
day they behave like a woke parallel
government
the left knows that so they engage in
politics in a much more effective way
because they go where the power really
is not the fantasy of where where
power used to be a hundred years ago
this is why i think what uh what you
guys over the daily wire
are doing with movies and things is so
important building culture and that's
why i
um want to do the exact same thing right
so i mentioned we have like this
paranormal writer who's joining
we want to write more than just news
right doing a show
about um ghosts and bigfoot yeah it
sounds really silly a lot of people who
are
uh much more intelligent or well-versed
in
politics might be like how is this going
to explain to people what's happening
and say no no it's not what it's going
to do is
it's going to get a bunch of regular
people who don't understand anything to
be like oh i love
timcast.com they do that bigfoot show
it's amazing oh cool
what's he saying about politics what's
he saying about government well you'll
also see on the website
news stories yeah and then you might
click on a new story and say i didn't
realize russia gate was fake news
because i only ever watch cnn so we do
things that are fun
to create a welcoming inspirational and
fun place
where you can also get access to
information that you maybe won't get
into these other places like culture
building is so important breitbart knew
it
yeah politics is downstream from culture
the left is fighting in that arena
and when it comes to like this this uh
this general
million the things he's saying what what
do you think
i'll say this there's a there's a phrase
out of sight out of mind
you ever you ever you ever noticed that
thing where you'll hear a word for the
first time and then also and you'll hear
it everywhere
or you'll see a car for the first time
then also you'll buy a car and then also
you see
you see it everywhere yeah yeah i don't
i don't know but it's it's the general
idea you know out of sight out of mind
when you're thinking of something you'll
start to see it more if you constantly
fight the culture war
in the leftist terms then what happens
is
you are arguing is critical race theory
the idea that x y and z right or wrong
what happens then is you have a lot of
people say critical race theory huh i
agree with it i critical right there i
disagree with it what if instead of even
arguing about critical race theory you
argue gun rights
so no one was even talking about those
ideas those ideas would
never spread well the other republicans
and conservatives don't fight on their
own battlefield and you know
probably the most sympathetic historian
of critical theory martin j
who i actually discuss in this book
speechless he
martin j made this point that critical
theory is not so much
an academic system as it is a gadfly on
other systems
so critical theory is just this
analytical lens that kind of infiltrates
history and literature and just every
now it's infiltrating the hard sciences
for goodness sake it's fire
yes it's just kind of spreading
throughout the university but yeah and
you know
on the breitbart point though i do think
there needs to be an addendum or a
caveat to it which is
what breitbart said is true culture
influences politics no doubt
but because what he said is a slogan and
all slogans are wrong
it also needs to be corrected which is
culture is downstream of politics
too but politics influences culture i
think of uh east germany east germany is
atheist today west germany is religious
today
it ain't because of the bratwurst it's
because of the officially
atheist government that dominated there
for decades and decades so i just think
the left
it could be they killed all of those
people and all that's left you know for
real though yeah yes and you think
that's politics the the left is really
good at making movies and and coming up
with stupid academic theories
not anymore well i suppose that you will
yes and no i'll get into that in a
second
they also engage in the politics right
they also dominate on that too
you you do have a good point though on
you know they're still the ones making
the movies
but they are increasingly unwatchable
did you see the
karen trailer is this oh my god is it
real
i don't know it is really i don't know
yeah
what it's like a movie about this like
white neighbor who harasses her black
neighbors
right it's bad did you see it i don't i
don't must i can't
but is it supposed to be like that movie
the room where it's just really bad
funny but even that was supposed to be
good tommy rizzo really
thought it was well he's now claiming it
was meant to be better
sure but it became a cult classic so you
know you got
you got to watch out for that but then
you look at things like ghostbusters
yeah there are a lot of movies
no no you know you don't take the cake
as the craft have you seen the new
the craft no you remember the 90s one no
i didn't see the old the craft the old
the craft was the old the craft was uh
uh who was who was in that movie i don't
remember
but there's like four girls and they're
witches
and they fight each other or something
yeah uh it it's not bad i'd give it a c
plus it's an old 90s movie they remade
the craft
and it basically was a nonsensical
non-plot with a bunch of woke talking
points
yeah like no joke like there's a scene
where for no reason
one of the witches just mentions that
they're trans and has nothing to do with
the plot nothing
it moves nothing forward it was
literally just they just say it was
probably a sag after a mandate it's like
we need one trans character in this
movie
there was a scene where they turn a
bully gay with magic
or some something like that i think
that's what they did huh and the whole
movie i'm just like i don't understand
what the movie's about
yeah because and i thought about it and
i was like whoa
i remember like what we talked about
this before that's a good flicks or
something
yes purification where it's like low
quality
like religious right-wing stuff but now
it's like something changed where
we're starting to see conservatives like
the daily wire make
run hide fight which is actually a
really well-made movie
and that was not just like you know
wholesome i mean it's kind of a gritty
movie yeah yeah
yeah uh and then you're starting to see
the left make these really awful movies
and i'm wondering if in like 10 years
the left is gonna be a bunch of
pseudo-religious cult
doctrine videos they already are right
right right
and then conservatives and the
anti-walker to be making fun adventure
movies there is this problem when you
watch the
the karen trailer the problem with it as
with all bad art
is when it doesn't ring true right the
thesis of karen according to the trailer
is that white people especially white
women are these
racists who are more likely to commit
hate crimes if you just
look at the federal government
statistics
there is not an epidemic of whites
committing hate crimes whites are
significantly less
likely to commit hate crimes as a
portion of their population
than black people are black people are
more likely relative to their population
to commit a hate crime
what is a hate crime i mean i think the
term is stupid to begin with because
it's
it's the opposite of a love crime i
guess i don't know but but
just even if you're going to take it on
its own terms it just doesn't ring true
i i got to be honest too it's like i i i
don't like the idea of hate crimes and i
don't like the idea
that um i think if someone quits a crime
they committed a crime yeah you know
what i mean like
they they we keep hearing and even even
some conservatives when it comes to the
anti-riot bills
they're like make the penalty harsher
and i'm like well if you enforced the
first penalty
yeah you would need to make it harsher i
don't care if someone's black
white asian latino gay straight whatever
if they're violent against somebody they
committed a crime
we stop them going after them and with
harsher penalties due to motives
is insane because it requires mind
reading i'm okay with premeditation
rules because like if you do plan it i
mean maybe there's like a
impetus of psychosis there that's a
little more dangerous for society but
that's just
another fact right we you can actually
prove if someone
planned it you're not asking about the
motivations that went into the plan
you're just saying
here here we go we know this guy thought
it out and that's different than
manslaughter
i i i gotta i gotta point this out i did
pull up the cnn article about the karen
trailer
and it's actually getting flack because
people are claiming they're just ripping
off get out
no the difference is get out was a good
movie yeah i mean i don't want to make
any i haven't seen obviously karen yet
the trailer doesn't look very good
but get out is a good movie about the
fears of assimilation
right it's the the fear that when you
assimilate into a culture
you lose your soul so that and it made
fun of white liberals which i got a kick
out of specifically
right we voted for obama but they're the
evil people they're the evil people
so it's it actually i thought it was a
kind of original movie i got a kick out
of it
this at least from the trailer i can't
judge the movie just looks like it's
it's falling into the myth of the evil
karen michael i've seen the trailer and
um
you're wrong this will be the citizen
kane of our generation oh my
[Laughter]
it did you see did god did you show the
photo of this guy i did look at this
oh dude it's so it's so silly have you
seen um
the hunt you know i wanted to but i
thought didn't it get pulled
i thought they brought it back they
ended up publishing but they did
publicly i thought it was great
it was good i loved the idea the idea
was well so initially
the hunt the trailer was liberals
kidnapping conservatives and then
hunting them
yeah and so my initial reaction was like
this is not the time
to be fed in the flames of this stuff
even donald trump was against it yeah i
i i i
changed my mind later on when i when i
was like you know i shouldn't be against
artful depictions and i shouldn't play
that game about you know criticizing a
movie i haven't seen
and then it turns out when i watch the
movie it's actually really good yeah
well because it's
i don't think it's advocating that the
liberals go out and kidding they're the
bad guys they're the bad guys
so so it's actually like you've got
two different factions in this movie
snooty liberal elites
who are who are just they hate these
right-wing conspiracy theorists so much
they want to kill them yeah
and then you have just dumb right-wing
conspiracy theorists where you're kind
of annoyed by them believing stupid
things
but they're not bad people this is goofy
people this is what's actually giving me
hope you know you say that steve bannon
says we're winning and you know i
i'll believe it when i see it i've been
you know i've been burned too many times
folks
but but the thing that does give me hope
when these
people of all different colors parents
of all different shapes and sizes all
around the country
show up to yell about critical race
theory i i see your point i think it's a
fair one that we shouldn't be arguing
with their language and that's a problem
sure and we can try to fix that but the
very fact
that these people are showing up these
ordinary americans
and then snooty elites radical elites
make
fun of them call them i don't you might
say deplorable irredeemable bitter
clinger or what
and you are further alienating the
common sense american people
from this ruling class that absolutely
despises them
that is in real time a win for
conservatives yes
yes i think bannon's point is when these
children come back from school on day
one
and mom says what did you learn in
school that you're evil yeah
what come again so i'm interested though
um in the same in the same i i do want
to talk about the loudoun stuff but
we'll get to that in a bit
in terms of movies like this this karen
one considering how like
really over the top the trailer is i'm
wondering if that'll have a similar
effect if if people start seeing movies
like this
where it display i mean this is it this
is culture right in the movie the hunt
the liberal elite to the bad guys
i'm gonna a spoiler alert for anybody
who hasn't seen it you care if i spoil
it or spoil it
the woman who's leading the liberals is
kidnapping people because they were
spreading conspiracy theories about her
online and her friends
decided to help her out it turns out one
of the women who was kidnapped i think
she was like former military
and it was the wrong name so what it
turns out is this innocent woman
was being harassed and they were trying
to kill her and she had nothing to do
with their politics
and i thought that was a really
interesting message based on what we're
seeing in the political landscape
regular people who don't care who don't
want to be involved are being forced
into it and accused of being racist and
being monsters
and now are being forced to fight for
their lives so when i see something like
this karen movie
a lot of people have already said karen
is like is a racial slur and you
shouldn't say it i've had people email
me like tim
don't use that word yeah i mean i guess
it literally is a racial i'll say it
yeah
you know but it is a racial slur it
references specifically like
white chicks yeah like white age yeah
sort of ages well
becky is a young karen yeah exactly
that's what they've been saying
and so i i wonder though how many women
named karen had no
no issues in politics didn't care and
then all of a sudden started feeling bad
because people were insulting them based
on their name my friend's daughter's
name is isis
oh man he was named before the action
so there was a there was a meme of um
there there was a meme of of a mom yeah
and it was like a strict mom meme i
can't remember exactly what it was
and it was a woman like sitting down in
a photo that people use in these old
school memes with like the sunburst
behind it and it would say like
you know makes you clean your room and
then grounds you or something like that
and the woman in the photo was like
i'm not like that at all i'm like a nice
person and people are using this image
of me to represent something nasty
i have to wonder if hollywood keeps
making movies
that insult regular americans simply
because their name is karen
yeah i'm not saying they keep making
karen movies i'm saying if
if they do things like this that insult
into ride people is this the kind of
thing that's going to make someone go
i don't i don't feel good you're making
me feel bad i reject you
i i hope that that is the case because
it really it pains me to hear these
stories that you're mentioning of
you know someone who says well i i'm not
like that i'm not one of them i'm one of
the good karens or whatever
i'm the good isis uh but
[Laughter]
but but the you have to come to the
realization
if you are in any way conservative and
by the way
it's not even on the racial politics if
you're just white if you're
black but you go along with the
conservative point of view you are
considered just as bad if not worse
you're saying if you're his i guess if
you're a traitor it's the apostates that
are a bigger threat
yeah and and i think what all these
people need to recognize is
the radical left hates you you are not
you can't charm your way out of it
you can't reason your way out of it i
know there's been a lot of talk now on
the internet about
whether or not one should engage in
debates then there were certain
crowder got ambushed by some libs or
something and there was there was
all of this debate me coward and all
this kind of stuff
i don't feel any compunction
about uh turning down a debate with
someone who hates me
because what's the what is the point of
that debate if i if i feel something
productive can come out of that i'll do
it but i don't feel any reason
well this is really fascinating
especially in terms of the crowder stuff
because
you know ethan klein is not a partic a
political individual
he was making comments about stephen
crowder i don't know how it started
um do you guys know how it started or
what she was oh
yeah what happened yeah so uh ethan was
saying that you don't need to do any of
your own research you just
trust the cdc whatever they say you
don't even have to do any homework and
his wife is just like uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh and i was like what what they're
telling they have like and
then crowder responded yeah he had
issues with that he's like why would you
tell people to not do their own homework
that doesn't make sense
that's actually against uh uh i think
that's that might be against youtube's
rules
interesting to say not to questioning
well no it's
that's that's it um just to tell people
how to think about it
you need to tell uh youtube's rules are
that you can't discourage people from
seeking the expert medical opinions so
the cdc
might youtube might be like that's fine
i guess you can blindly follow them but
nobody
yeah no no but i think like youtube says
you can't discourage people from
talking to medical experts for advice
and saying you don't have to do anything
just follow the cdc
those aren't your doctors so i wonder i
should have debated ethan well so
uh well ethan isn't a political figure
he's a drama grifter
like his whole thing is like i had never
heard of it i had no
even the other guy i hadn't hadn't seen
he's interesting because they're kind of
under the radar but they're hugely
popular they just weren't like ever
front
and center mainstream they kind of came
up they got interested
they get like millions of views in their
massive massive show so so the issue
though is
this is why i would say you got to be
careful about who you do debate like
we're gonna we're gonna have vosh back
on
okay uh you're familiar with him he's
like he's a leftist youtube person i've
heard of him i haven't seen his stuff
but i have heard
he's a he's a socialist or he's i
believe he's a socialist he's
he's a lefty uh gamer and then we're
also um planning on having on another
uh a few other leftist personalities
people who actually i think want to
engage
in the uh robust challenge of a good
debate like i think vosh loved it
because he had a bunch of clips where
they said i was dumb and of course we
got
clips where they were like he's dumb but
i think we had a lot it was like four
hours yeah but there are some people
like the guy
who ambushed stephen crowder this guy's
a con man
this guy's whole shtick is to generate
drama and so the issue is
stephen crowder wants to engage in a
legitimate conversation with ethan klein
ethan klein being a drama channel
yeah just turn the camera camera off
runs away and then says
here you go here's drama crowder walked
right into that one i think crowder was
correct to say hey ethan let's let's
let's let's talk
yeah and then when you release the full
audio you actually see they were being
very nice to each other and they were
like talking about family
and then ethan goes like haha i gotcha
ambushes crowder with a guy who's known
for not getting a lot of traffic yeah
and for trying as hard as possible to
get bigger channels to debate him so he
can get views
so crowders like i have no obligation to
give you the time of day
you've been blacklisted by so many other
channels they refuse to talk to you and
i'll tell you this
behind the scenes a bunch of podcast
networks have already blacklisted
i'm not saying his name on purpose yeah
because he doesn't this is what he tries
to do he tries to use drama to get
attention
he's been blacklisted by a bunch of very
big podcasts even some more lefty ones
because he's viewed as a drama baiter
yeah who tries to get attention by just
causing fights and stuff like that yeah
but you know the right opens themselves
up to these kinds of attacks
when they go into the sort of the free
marketplace of ideas must always prevail
and we must always debate everything
with everybody and
we can never cancel or ostracize anybody
and i think
that's not true that's never been true i
i
not only do i have no obligation to
engage with somebody who's just a
shyster or some kind of jerk you know i
there's no re it's actually
counterproductive to do that
no one will learn anything no honesty
this is why i say um from this point
forward
i think it should be clear to everybody
ethan klein should be off
limits for any any legitimate political
uh podcast
of course the left will probably engage
with them because they're going to be
like hey it's an opportunity to get
views
and they like what he did but for
anybody who is
moderate anti-woke or wants to have a
legitimate conversation so this would be
like intellectual dark web types as well
as any other legitimate news news outlet
you you can't do it yeah not not with
somebody who's willing to poison
the political discourse for personal
gains what's you
you think about how dumb most debates
are it's really sad because
not that long ago you go back like 30
years there were pretty
popular debates that would air on tv or
certain areas burrows was pretty
well-known yeah or you think firing line
or those kind of shows
and now they're just really dumb and
it's just like two heads screaming at
each other for five minutes on cable tv
or something
and i just think i it's so degrading
there's a political
rule that i i learned years ago and i
think i violated it a couple times at my
own peril
never wrestle with a pig if you wrestle
with a pig you will both get dirty
but the pig will like it so
you know you know what i uh i would give
this advice to stephen
uh and to anybody who finds himself in
one of these situations
if i agreed to do an interview with
someone like ethan and they decided to
pull up one of these you know con
you know individuals as soon as it
popped up
i wouldn't laugh i would say ethan look
i got very little time
i know we agreed to have a conversation
i'm not interested in talking to this
guy
yeah i mean no disrespect but i'm going
to respectfully say no to this
circumstance and if you want to
reschedule i'm more than happy to have a
nice day yeah
click yeah of course but i guess you
know in order to say that
we need to have standards right we need
to actually say like here's what i want
to do here's the purpose of the debate
here are the guard rails here's what
we're going to do and i just feel like
we can't articulate it it gets back to
what we were talking about earlier did
you say
yeah michael did you ever debate in high
school because i did and one of the
first things you do when you go into
debate is you lay out your definitions
yeah like you go into it with the
understanding of what the words are what
exactly they mean
if we could do that that'd be great but
nobody does that anymore so debates
meaningless i mean we can't even in the
broader culture
the words i mean this happens to be the
subject of my book but
but the word we actually can't agree on
even the definition of man or woman so
obviously
we can't agree on on the right on the
the rules of this sort of a debate
and the problem for it in the broader
politics is
the left getting back to your culture
point tim the left has a narrative about
the country
what is america to the left america is
an evil rotten bigoted place that was
founded by white guys to preserve their
own property so that they can rape kill
pillage and burn
you now have someone on the american
olympic team or i suppose an alternative
to the american olympic team saying they
want to burn the flag it should have
been removed immediately
obviously it's rejected so so incoherent
to be on the team
and want to destroy the country but but
the left has that narrative and i guess
my question for the right is what's your
story about him what's america
conservatives what and i actually don't
you'll forget a hundred different
answers but i don't think you have one
oh i can't
what is it north america america uh the
united states of america was an
ideological revolution one of the first
times in history that human beings
realized government was derived from the
will of the people and not divine
providence
that due to a variety of uh issues
pertaining to the separation of the
power of the crown in europe with the
thousands of miles to the united states
there were individuals who were more
reliant and dependent upon themselves
which they then came to realize through
the teachings of people like locke
and their own experiences that the king
simply
saying by decree by divine providence
they were in charge made little no sense
on how they lived their lives
so it was an ideological revolution of
classical liberalism
freedom of the individual life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness and an
ultimate separation
from another government which was both a
physical political and ideological
revolution
what america represents to me is one of
the most profound and brilliant things
ever
because while we have mocked the idea of
the failures of modern americans
exporting democracy
as if as if you know i love the american
dad joke where they're in
uh they're in i think saudi arabia and
they're like no
i can't remember where they were but
like democracy kicked in and then
everything
everything changes and like women are
wearing daisy dukes and like right
people are cracking beers like that's
not gonna happen but
a lot of our mechanisms and our ideas
did actually influence the world and
this idea that the government is derived
from the will of the people
this is the reason in my opinion why
everybody so desperately wants to come
here
because you can have a say the american
dream exists and it doesn't so many
countries
still have landed gentry in control of
politics or
hereditary monarchy so america means a
lot
okay now i'm going to prove my own
theory
by disagreeing with your history of
america now i think you're i think the
account you give is fair enough and i
think a lot of people would agree with
it but
i would point out our founding fathers
wrote at considerable length about
providence
they thought that the country was
brought about in this
liberal revolution some might say but
through
providence i mean the very fact that
washington escaped from brooklyn
was an act of god the very fact that
this man survived his horse getting shot
out from under him multiple times was
seen to be
an act of god and of course there's a
deep christian
history to america the the pilgrims land
at plymouth rock and
and then two indians walk out of the
woods speaking one
okay english and one nearly perfect
english these are like the only two guys
in the hemisphere that speak
english that's unbelievable i don't
think that that's at odds necessarily
right now
the idea was that certainly they were
very religious
yeah very christian but the king simply
just asserted his power to rule
the the divine right right yes yes and
uh well we can get into divine right
later but yes i agree with your
obviously they they leave the king they
don't establish a monarchy in america
but i guess the
the problem for this is in in your
telling america begins
in 1776 but there are other dates you
can choose as the new york times told us
i've often dated america to 1620 to the
landing of
the mayflower but you could date america
to a dozen years earlier
to the landing at jamestown where there
was a landed gentry i also don't think
that disagrees with uh with what i'm
saying
uh when was when when was luck it was it
was late 1600s right
sure so this is a hundred years before
the founding fathers ever decided to
form that explanation of independence
but the american revolution was over the
span of i think 20 some odd years
it wasn't that one day they signed a
declaration it was the culmination of
so much and more importantly i think
you're right i think it perhaps could
have been the pilgrims landing it may
flower upon the rock all that stuff
it was when people separated themselves
from the from the
literally the continent on which they
were being ruled
and found their own lives and had to
make the rules for themselves
but then is the story one of separation
or one of continuity because i think
that the libs would tell us that the
story of america
is that we totally rejected the old
world but i think the conservatives
following the example of edmund burke
would tell us
no actually unlike the french revolution
which was a radical revolution
the american revolution was a
conservative revolution because we
we actually kept our rights of
englishman i mean when when the
americans rebel
they're rebelling as englishmen to say
you're we're not being treated with the
with the respect that englishmen deserve
so it obviously creates a separation but
there's also this great continuity
as well and it's very difficult to trace
that story i talked to some friends of
mine who are from texas say
and to them america is the wild west
it's the settling of the west right
obviously it's where they are
i come from the northeast that's the
that's the american story you talk to
people in the south
that's the american story so what is it
i mean it gets to this this insight by
the lake rate roger scrutin who says
it's it's much easier to destroy than it
is to build
so it's very easy for for hannah nicole
jones it's much harder for conservatives
but i i do think we need a story i think
we need to say
this is what america stands for and
you're telling other tim is
a pretty good one you know so i'm not
i'm not saying that's not a good i think
we
i think we can just simplify and say we
agree with the idea of life liberty the
pursuit of happiness
sure yeah but what yes i'm not
disagreeing with you i'm just saying
don't we need something practical don't
we need something tangible i mean the
left they point at you and they say
washington evil
you you ian evil you know you this
country that's slavery and they're
pointing all these times you say the
same thing back
we just say we say washington oh don't
fight
there yeah
frankfurt school evil yeah you know yeah
critical theory evil
and i got to be honest they are i mean
think about it just think for two
seconds that the founding fathers
who had a lot of really bad ideas in
terms of how they lived culturally i
mean slavery for one
but they laid the groundwork the seeds
were planted for liberty
which led to really smart and amazing
people harriet tubman frederick douglass
and
incredible writing that ultimately ended
slavery
in a bloody battle over this the you
know to end this this
this uh horrific uh institution
it's the things we have today civil
rights one of the most
respectful countries on the planet in
terms of your right to identify however
you choose
would not exist that the founding
fathers recognizing life liberty in the
pursuit of happiness but is th is that
not just the progressive telling i mean
yes of course we say like it's nice that
you know
there's no jim crow you know it's nice
that people have their rights you
can look at certain countries that have
like what india still has a caste system
yeah so the founding fathers probably
didn't envision everything as it is
today
but the framework they laid out led to
arguments go to the supreme court
we make decisions the issue is the
reason why i say they are
evil not all of them but look at chrissy
tygan direct message where the guy says
please i've never said these words
before and she's like
right i'm gonna do whatever i want like
evil stuff you look at uh
that kathy griffin lady cut showing
trump's severed head like that's insane
yeah
and then you look at steven crowder
saying i'd like to have a reasonable
conversation
and then they ambush him laugh cut
things out of context and then say we
win
they don't want a political conversation
they don't want things to improve they
just want to watch the world burn
yes i i just i want to be even more
depressing about it i feel like you're
not being depressing enough
the more depressing thing is i fear
we've all kind of imbibed this
progressive history
because we say some things have gotten
better so we say you know
we give credit for the founding fathers
for setting us up from that terrible old
time to this great new time
and the left hates the founding fathers
because they say they tolerated this bad
time in the old past but now we have
this good new time
but but what if it's even worse than
that what if
the time we're living in is no better
than the time the founding fathers lived
in
what if we don't have slavery today
relatively well first of all we do yeah
and we and we
buy our iphones which are made by slaves
right and the left rebels in it
yeah they won't and they don't talk
about it but but even some do some do i
gotta respect
a lot of activists sure they but they
all have iphones exactly i mean you have
people declaring bankruptcy because they
can't pay their medical debt it's like
indentured servitude in a way
and college and just yeah and just take
the most obvious example
we we kill a million babies a year
legally legally in this country right
now we kill
a million babies a year i suspect
that some future generation is going to
come to grips
with this moral horror and they're going
to look at us and say huh
though in that that wonderful new time
that they were all living in
that that seems perhaps more evil than
the old time it replaced but is it just
two steps forward one step back
is is it that there really are two steps
back no no i agree
there's a lot of things that have come
about more recently that have been
really bad i mean the progressives of
the of the early 1900s were eugenicists
yeah right and wasn't wasn't margaret
sanger wasn't she she was a leading
founder of planned parenthood and the
leading eugenicist right
so certainly bad things came about and
still exist
but it's not like we're we'll never be
without conflict but our our current
understanding of free speech for
instance
is relatively new you didn't have free
speech back in the day you had obscenity
laws i'm so glad to hear you say this
because this is something that the
conservatives say my beloved fellow
conservatives
that drives me crazy they say we had
freer speech back in the day and now
we're being censored
like we in some ways we had better
speech back in the day
but in many ways you are much freer to
say what you want to say today than you
i mean you can say whatever you want on
tv remember george carlin
he got him to say arrested for his his
comedy routine yeah and it was um
i think was it brandenburg the ohio that
set the current standard we understand
also i was researching gun rights laws
gun rights were way more restrictive in
the 80s yeah and it's and now we're
getting constitutional carry
it used to be may issue not shell issue
for concealed carry permits meaning
most of the states in this country would
be like we're not giving you a concealed
capability you can't do anything about
it yeah now laws have been passed that
actually have expanded our rights i'm
like sounds like we're winning in this
regard
but oh but i'd actually like to take
again the more pessimistic view i feel
like you know
when we say that we have freer speech
now one i
think that's got a bad bad understanding
of lib of liberty to it
but also i liked the obscenity laws
i did i liked the laws against sedition
i liked the laws against fraud and
liability they're still on the books
right they're still on the books today
we we threw a pornographer in federal
prison a dozen years ago
just for pornography he didn't if he
didn't have child porn he didn't rape
someone on his
he just produced obscene pornography
and that guy rotted for almost four
years in prison
the founding fathers loved that
conservatives loved that
the reason is the obscenity is not
legitimate speech it was their argument
they would say that obscenity is just a
form of licentiousness
liberty in america should not be abused
to licentiousness the founding fathers
said
that self-government only works if
you've got virtue and morality and
religion and
so what what many people would herald is
the wonderful expansion of free speech
frankly i see it as the the undermining
of free speech do you think our
discourse
is freer and more sophisticated today
or attack it's it's corrupt
you know and broken yeah i i we had to
do two things right i want to make sure
we
we we talk about your book but there was
something i was trying to talk about
back we were talking about this general
and i think we had a great conversation
but let's go back
i want to talk about the um
ramifications of a woke military
yeah because the the wokeness has spread
far and wide to the point where one of
our generals is saying so what's so
wrong about reading mao and
doing all these things and uh we make
jokes about basic training and
you know soy boys coming out i guess i
don't know if you saw this story but
this one
from the washington post russia says it
fired warning shots at a british warship
in the black sea
the uk says it didn't i don't
necessarily believe the uk
russians also say they were dropping
bombs in the path of the of the british
warship because they entered crimean
waters
this freaks me out see the the us nato
was doing
big war games russia then counters with
their own war games
we see the hms trent royal navy going
through the boss first straight only a
few weeks ago then
the hms defender entering crimean waters
which russia is claiming its own so it's
occupied waters
doesn't matter who you think belong it
belongs to we are dangerously close to
conflict china came out and said
that they will join russia in a
counter-attack against the us
now is not the time for our general to
come out and say
i am pathetic and weak and have no
have no strength of will of my own mind
well the problem is that
xi jinping and putin they have youtube
and they saw that woke army and they
said
the lesbian mothers and they probably
invade today invade
and of course they were inviting the
aggression you see putin praise
joe biden he's focused you got to pay it
you got you got to pay attention
and then i see these these these biden
voters on facebook being like
even putin's recognizing that joe
biden's strong republicans
are so are trying to make like
republicans want putin to win because
they hate biden so much
but even even putin recognizes biden is
is not losing his mind and i'm like
putin wants to destroy us and wants us
to keep voting for the
the man who has no lucidity left so that
he can win a war
so obviously you had trump trump's
foreign policy whatever you think of the
individual incidents
the genius of it of course was you just
never knew what this guy was going to do
i mean do you remember he called kim
jong-un
short and fast just cuz
just because he had insulted i mean this
is a pretty wild guy you know he he took
out the top general and he was called
the dotard he was called
yeah that's right yeah and and so he
goes in
and you know but then he assassinates
iran's top general he drops
bombs in various but it totally
unpredicted right then he pulls some
troops out
with biden biden just is the avatar of
the liberal establishment right he is
he's just the same guy the top brass in
the navy talking about man it's just
whatever is in the zeitgeist that's what
biden is and
the the sad fact is if you know
that you're going to get a traditional
liberal establishment foreign policy
of course you're going to aggress in the
south china sea if you're ji jinping
do you really think the american people
are ready for a war to defend
taiwan no no way not to get involved and
i've
i've been advised i think were you gonna
say steve steve yeah yeah he was
explicitly like no no we're not it's
silicon valley it's
he's called it silicon valley west we
lose taiwan we lose our computer chips
no more trucks
no more cars no more computers do you
think
you think the american people are are
seriously concerned at the moment
about deterring putin from further
aggression and crimea
oh no it's so far away if it was cuba
yeah yeah
i don't even know about that i think
they're so concerned about
like look a general came out and said
he's reading mao
and and lenin and he's
having the troops study the the
real history to understand this country
wow yeah it's you just feel so
crestfallen
it's just it's so i mean we were joking
about how we need to make it even more
depressing but it does you know you i
mean truly
you've gotta on the first step to
recovery you need to recognize
that you've got a problem this this rot
runs so
so deep i don't i do still think there
is some hope i think there's a glimmer
of hope because the american people are
repulsed by this sort of thing but
they're really
depressed by it i think when you see
that russian
military ad where it shows like this
this super chat
this rip super chad shaved head and he
puts the hood on and then he's like
he's looking down he's all angry and
then he jumps out of the the plane and
parachutes and then he lands he's got a
bolt action rifle
and it's dark colors and it's like that
and you're like whoa
yeah that's that's a tough that's it
then you see the other one where it's
like going to the parade and like
to be fair though that was an army ad
yeah and the marine corps ad
is still a bit more you know it's like a
guy he's walking down the street in a
cyberpunk future
and then an advertisement pops up saying
buy shoes and it's like
you know pointing out that people have
no purpose and then he falls
forward through the hologram and lands
in the mud and gets up and he's got a
rifle and they're like go go
go and then he's moving through the
woods that was a bit more on point with
war and conflict yeah so maybe the army
is looking for administrators and the
marine corps is looking for warriors
but but right now i mean that's that
actually does give me a little hope
right and i'm sure the marines are
gloating over this yeah
but but you know even among
conservatives right now
so-called conservatives they're going to
be people who say well you know i think
actually
if a transgender person wants to observe
in the military that's perfectly fine
well you know i think women should be in
combat positions and well i think you
just think
oh oh so you're not serious about this
either i don't think that there is
anyone advocating for trans
soldiers in putin's russia or xi jinping
well but i don't i i
i if somebody wants to uh
go shoot the bad guys i don't care who
they are what they think they are
i don't know identify if um if a guy
thinks he's a woman
and is demanding really crazy medical
treatments
and it clearly doesn't have his grip on
reality
i don't think i want that guy in the
military call call me an extremist but
it seems like there's a problem there's
some logic to you know you want sane
strong
people next to you in in combat if they
fall
then you're you have no protection on
the side and by the way you know the
reason i don't want women in combat
is not because i don't think women are
perfectly capable obviously they're not
as physically strong as men which is why
they're losing all the weightlifting
competitions now including including in
the olympics
two men but it's because i think it's
wrong for society
to send its women to go fight i think
it's disordered i think men and women
are different
i think we have different roles we are
complementary we're not identical
and i don't want to live in a world in
which i've got a
lovely graceful woman fighting my wars
for me well so so the issue comes down
to
um i guess what's the right word
you've got by any means necessary
victories
and moral victory if you have a country
that says
we will send wave after wave of our own
people we don't care who they are how
tall they are with their man if they're
a woman or they're trans they're gay
they're straight whatever
we will give them a gun and send them
your way but don't you think like
the fact is women are just not as strong
i this is not insulting to women it's
just a natural fact
and so if you've got an army of all big
tough dudes who look like super chad
from the russian ad
that is going to be a stronger army than
a mixed army with women
but but that that's under the uh
assumption that we
lose some of our servicemen
by adding service women you see what i'm
saying like if we have let's say we had
a million
uh well-trained well-world machine
marines and then we're like we got this
hey we also got a hundred thousand women
that's just a benefit in my opinion well
i mean but we're also not
we're not napoleon's army we're not
launching these you know million person
land wars
and i suppose this one of the arguments
i'm not saying that women have no role
in helping out the military i just
specifically i'm talking about comedy
oh historically you have a few women
like thomaris was a scythian queen
and she was a warrior queen and
basically stomped out the persians
more or less um you had like boudicca
who was a celtic
queen that fought against the romans so
you get these i don't know if they were
like beastial
monstrosities of monster humans i don't
know but they were apparently fire like
warriors like they would slash and kill
and
yeah but i think generally what you're
talking about is more of a general fact
that
that one can name them i think is kind
of i think the idea from the modern
military in that regard is
how do we add more people to combat
roles it's like well women aren't
serving can we get them to serve sure
but do we increases the number do we
have a shortage of
of fighters i don't think so i mean we
don't you know the first of all the wars
we wage are mostly from like
office buildings in new jersey where
we're fighting with video games to blow
up bad guys in
syria but i don't i if we had a genuine
shortage
of people who were able to hold a gun
and shoot it then i suppose that's a
conversation
i think it comes down to this for me um
we should have a standard
you should have to pass that standard
they shouldn't reduce the standard for
anybody
and so i think that's one of the issues
people are concerned about is of course
yeah i mean
they're they in some circumstances some
uh departments and like fire departments
and police have lowered standards
in in all circumstances virtually right
i mean
but so that's a problem too but i'd like
to take it even further
let's say that there is a woman you know
some great ancient queen
who's an amazonian who's you know
destroys the persian army uh
all well and good i still think just as
a social matter
as a matter of the way that men and
women interact with one another as a
matter of chivalry darn it
the age of chivalry is gone that of
sophisters economists and calculators
has succeeded it
and the glory of europe is extinguished
forever to quote the great edmund burke
i think that's bad i want the glory back
i want the chivalry back i want
i want a world in which men and women
are not seem to be identical or
indiscernible
or at odds with one another but one of
the one of the arguments that is that
there will never be a war with between
the sexes because everyone's sleeping
with the enemy
i want them to be complimentary again
and that requires people observing
certain limits both men and women yeah
it's a very unpopular view i suppose but
i think it happens i i think what ends
up happening is
people start scraping the bottom of the
barrel in their conflicts and things
just
get weird i i will say i will say one
thing um a lot of what we talk about
especially when it comes to women in
combat and um you mentioned obscenity
laws
yeah we wouldn't need laws or policy
if people had a shared moral framework
within their culture or
it would certainly would not be nearly
as necessary because
but but again the law kind of reflects
the culture
right and but the law also influences
the culture jordan peterson talked about
enforced monogamy
and immediately these leftists were like
assuming he was saying women should be
like physically forced to be in
relationships with like nasty men with
me yeah yeah with you
but what he meant was and correct me if
i'm wrong so i think you know lydia
might you know you might know this
what he meant was just there were
societal pressures that you were in a
relationship you had an obligation
and if you didn't uphold your your
contract then you were looked down upon
that right that was that that's correct
and when jordan peterson made this point
i don't know if he realized this at the
time but he was tapping into something
that's absolutely pivotal
you need cultural pressure for the
things that you want you need it against
the things that you don't want that way
the government is not required to for
example censor speech
they can let other people do it oh you
shouldn't have done that mom says it to
her
you know i guess i i agree with jordan's
point i agree with what we're talking
about
but this distinction this neat
distinction between politics and culture
i think is a little blurrier because
when cultures and societies come to
certain decisions
let's say they want to pass blue laws
and you can't buy booze on sunday let's
say they want to ban porn or
prostitution or something
they come together and they have the
social more and they reflect that in
their law
and so these earlier ages which had
perhaps a more
moral and upright or at least virtue
conscious people also had
much stricter laws about obscenity and
these sorts of things but most people
didn't need the laws right it's it's an
interesting conundrum how that occurs
and
the laws in part form the people and the
people form the laws of course it's very
very blurry there's a really great meme
where it's a guy on his knee
opening up a ring for a woman and he
says will you enter into a
a government contract with me that
guarantees you get all of my stuff and
you can also leave it at any time
that's how i think by the way that's
that's a really important point though
it used to be that you could not get
divorced like the judges
a judge would be like you need to go to
counseling yes
you will you cannot divorce and and you
know now i i know that it is
unthinkable that we should possibly uh
make our divorce laws a little more
restrictive
but of course we should the the societal
breakdown
that has really ramped up over the past
40 50 years
is a direct result of no fault divorce
it has
ruined people's lives it has destroyed
society
if a a marriage bond means
nothing which practically i mean this is
your point and i'm not even i'm not even
just blaming the guys or just blaming
the girls
it's it's set up in such an unfair way
but if that bond means nothing
then you don't have trust as a society
that is a sacred vow you're making
not just before god that's pretty
important too but it's also a political
matter you're making it
before the public and you're saying we
will be in this bond
if you can just dissolve that
willy-nilly then your social trust
evaporates so let's talk about your book
that's my book is actually on
these sorts of topics exactly the book
is speechless
controlling words controlling minds as i
you may have heard of it before
i think i have someone super super
chatted did they
one or two yeah a couple of people i
think uh super chat
i do i have to thank i truly need to
thank
the viewers of this show you
a seriously if this book makes the list
if this book if the new york times is
forced to put this on the list
if which i don't think they would do it
willingly but it you know if they were
forced
if this book changes the conversation it
is because of the
insane viewers of this show
well they're fans of you it's wonderful
but i'll say it a million times
you know reading reading the super chats
was fun i want people to buy your book i
want people to buy michael malus's book
andy nose book a bunch of hero books
james o'keefe books
i want it so that when you go to
amazon.com and you click book
the top 10 are from anti-establishment
anti-woke
or just maybe voices you haven't heard
of yeah because for a long period what
were the top books like uh white
fragility oh yeah
right and so what happens is regular
people this is part of the information
where you're trying to
explain to people your ideas and win
hearts and win mines you know what was a
big one was becoming michelle obama
which i thought i don't know if you've
seen the conspiracy theory oh it's just
conspiracy theory of talking about
transgenderism
and i just thought if you're trying to
tamp down that conspiracy theory
don't title your book becoming a shallow
phone that's not a good idea
anyway you got to ignore the the weird
stuff to be honest that one's i know
what you took
it's pretty out there i i do not know i
know a guy who's like dude i swear i
watch these videos i'm like i know that
guys
stop first of all stop watching the
videos yeah i don't know why you're
looking at it
i want to say i love the cover i love
the art i don't know who did that does
this was hotly debated we went back and
forth
because some people some people believed
that
to sell the book we needed one of these
kind of sticky covers where i'm like
winking or something and you know
whatever i'm you know but i just thought
no i i actually am making an argument
here i don't
ever intend to write a book again it's
simply too much work i'm going to i'm
just only writing blank books from now
on that's good
going back to my original magnum opus
but i do want to make this argument here
because i just feel like i mean
kind of the central point of the book is
whatever we have done
to push back against woke-ism has
advanced woke-ism isn't that weird it's
just anything either we
obviously when you get into it it
advances it but even when we push back
really hard against it
still it advances it and it's because of
tim actually a lot of what you've been
saying tonight
which is we just don't have any
standards and we're not willing to
articulate them but it's not
it's not enough to point that out
because you actually then have to
articulate what the standard is and
that is not always popular this is why
years ago
i began a lot of people would describe
the the leftists as intersectionalists
or feminists
and i started calling them identitarians
yeah because identitarian is typically
used by white identitarians now
identitarianism
just means like identity and
government so it's policy predicated
upon your identity
of course the white identitarians really
loved using it and i said that's the
exact same thing as the critical race
theory stuff
and so i'm going to as someone who
doesn't like either i'll refer to them
all under the same name
i had a conversation with i had a
conversation with a friend who's like a
very prom
like a very prominent activist very you
know woke
and i just always refer to them as an
identitarian
it puts them in the same camp as the
white nationalists
they hate it but it's true do you have
to get more
i mean i i like this point because i you
know you have described
what the the conservatives keep messing
up which is they keep using the left's
own language
it's just just uh before you don't
forget that i just want to make the
simplified point
if you have a a red battlefield and a
blue battlefield
and you bring everyone onto the red
battlefield and say
red is the worst choice it's the only
thing that people are experiencing and
the only thing they'll talk about
yeah they won't even have an experience
of blue yeah you need to bring people to
your battlefield and make the left come
there to argue with you
so that instead of learning about
critical race theory they're learning
about
classical liberalism or conservative
values and making the left argue against
those preferably even the more
conservative ones
right you know i mean but it raises this
identity question because
you're not saying we can't have any kind
of identity obviously everybody's got an
identity i got my name i got my religion
i got my town i got my state i got my
country
that's an identity so you're calling out
in particular would seem
this racial identity maybe this kind of
crazy gender
identity but it does leave this question
open for you
which is what we were talking about
earlier in the show
who are we as a country and who am i
personally and i've got
an old-school catholic answer for you my
friends thank you
i've got finally here it is okay in the
bible
abraham moses rather asks god who are
you
what does god say i am i am i am
who i am i am who i am the essence of
being and
when you identify in that it's very easy
to
know who you are when you turn away from
that
well what am i i'm uh i'm i'm black i'm
uh
i'm a black lesbian a muslim ableist
cispan
it's really pathetic it's what little
it's what kids do when they try on
different different identities
but in order to recover that sense of a
national identity
you have to say certain things that are
exclusive claims
this is who we are and if we say this is
who we are it's like a nation with a
border
if we say this is the nation then it
means outside the name then that's not
the nation
if this identity in america and you
might say
it's the classical liberal idea or it's
this or it's the other thing but if we
say this is what it is
then what we are saying is if you don't
go along with that you are not an
american you are excluded
you are ostracized you might be outright
censored
are we willing to make that kind of a
claim one
one of the challenges that we've been
talking about for a while is that in
wartime
some of our greatest leaders did
horrifying things we talked about
abraham lincoln and we're
so happy the north won but the dude
suspended habeas corpus there's the
the rumor that he tried to get a supreme
court justice uh arrested
he did a lot of really bad things he
threatened the press were they were they
bad
threatening the press i mean these days
that's i think you should win the nobel
peace prize for that but uh
but it's it's it's doing what has to be
done to to win
and if we saw that happening today if
like donald trump you know when he
threatens the press the media shrieks
and howls
if uh if in order to win a war our civil
rights were curtailed we would be
furious 50 to 100 years on and it was
the right thing to do
sure and obviously there's a double
standard because you've got
the obama administration hounding the
press and harassing them
they obviously face no no consequences
for that so
yes we've become much more but i guess
this gets to my point
we've become much more individualistic
we've become much more
jealous about our individual some might
say licentious autonomy
to and we've totally lost a sense of
what brings us together you know a
republic
refers to the things we have in common
right the public things that we've got
we've got together
so if the left has lost that because
they've become insanely individualistic
on the
social side basically they want to have
sex with whoever they want to have sex
with or whatever right
and if the conservatives have become
insanely individualistic
on for a long time the economic side but
on certain aspects of
cherished civil liberties and nobody is
paying any attention to what we have to
do together
what you have to sacrifice what you have
to suppress what you have to tamp down
in order to have a country together then
obviously the country's going to fizzle
and balkanize well
this is why right balkanization is is
the best way to talk about the balkan
peninsula which is like the gr the greek
peninsula north of greece where it was
like just shattered into like croatia
and all these different little countries
and continues to shatter
and i think i think people have
mentioned peaceful divorce
but there have been many individuals for
years have been calling for
you know more extremists calling for
balkanization of the us yeah
and name a peaceful national divorce
that has ever taken place in history
you know it's the roman republic split
the roman empire split into the eastern
and western empire of course then that
caused
wars for years hundreds of years yeah
think about what's happening in the us
and as you mentioned
conservatives are too individualistic
yeah so they're not banding together the
way the left is the left is overly
a collectivist but the scary thing is
they have this insane moral ideology
and so then you're the libertarians yeah
you know and then and they're in their
space
so what happens well a bunch of states
start saying texas for instance we're
going to do what we want to do
have a nice day yeah and joe biden when
he comes out and speaks is clearly not
talking to
uh texas or florida yeah when you're
saying earlier in the year like oh we
gotta we gotta double down on masks and
we gotta
we gotta put more restrictions in place
texas and florida were open so who was
he talking to clearly not them
and that's what's gonna keep happening
it's not so much that conservatives are
necessarily too individualistic it's
just that
the tribe of conservatives is made up of
a bunch of smaller tribes
yes but they have no reason to come
together i mean there was a moment it's
called fusionism this was the post-cold
work
or post-world war ii conservative
movement where bill buckley and frank
meyer and others
brought together the libertarians and
the traditionalists and the
war hawk dems you know and later on the
neoconservatives to come and and fight
against the soviet union
soviet union goes away what exactly is
uniting the conservatives with the
libertarians they have
completely different accounts of human
nature they usually want rather
different things
as a matter of policy why they
when you consider the other aspects the
neoconservatives and others
they all broke apart during 2016. like
what what is the coalition
taxation anti-woke yeah yeah and
i hope anti-woke is the answer but i i
fear ian you're right i think the only
thing they ever agree on is
cut taxes that's and i like i like tax
cuts but i think anti-woke is a is a
massive component of it
and it's probably because i'm biased
because i hope you're right
i'm i'm not the most uh like lower the
taxes kind of individual
i was talking about the other day i
agree with him he says raise the taxes
on the rich
the one problem i said is giving
government money i don't know if that's
the answer to the problems
right we just need to eat the rich it's
amazing how the politics have really
realigned here yeah um but you know
everyone's always trying to find what
the dividing line is i don't think
there's one but there's
and there are many the media lies do you
believe
cnn or do you disbelieve do you think
they're lying well i think
that is a core component the matrix are
out of the matrix could be easily
describe it
and then i also think what versante will
cause is a very uh
core aspect of that as well because you
turn on msnbc and they say republicans
don't want to teach your children about
slavery
which is lie insane right absolute lies
yeah
and so do you believe the lies or do you
are you seeing reality and that's why
it's funny that's why they say it's red
pill but hasn't the
i guess i fear the balkanization has
already happened and we're just
realizing it you saw the secretary of
state anthony blinken
is now flying the progress flag at u.s
embassies around the world this is a new
this thing was invented like five
minutes ago and it's like the gay flag
with some other racial things and
transgender or something on it
but that is the new flag of the united
states that is rather i'll be more
specific
that is the flag of the liberal empire
so obviously the state department the
steward of the liberal empire
is going to fly all around the world the
american flag makes claims about america
the pride flag or even the blm flag
makes universal claims about everywhere
on earth
and when you look at twitter accounts
when you look at people's homes even
conservatives will fly the american flag
libs will fly the pride flag right those
are those are two different flags
ostensibly for the same country
but it's really now two countries kind
of living together
and these major corporations will change
their avatars to the pride flag
unless they're the saudi arabian bridge
yes that's true it's amazing do they not
have
they can't edit their twitter i guess
over in qatar maybe oh strange
well i actually think it might be
illegal no joke yeah so they literally
can't do it
sure and and i wonder i mean there's
such a push back against
the kind of craziness of the lgbt
transiting the kids drag queen story
hour
but the elites and the elite
institutions are all pushing this i mean
that
that is the new national identity so
if you're giving an account of what
america is i fear
that the pride flag as a matter of our
actual governing institutions
is more representative i'll i'll tell
you uh my issue with with the the
embassy's flying
flags other than the united states yeah
it
we we are the united states that is the
country that is the constitution is the
declaration of independence
you don't have to like the country
you're free to not like it but you are
in america you are governed by the
american government with social security
card and all that stuff
that flag is of of your country
but the american government is flying
the pride flag and that's where you see
that
they're flying the flag of 12 it's
between 8 and 12
of the country it is not the majority of
the left it is not the majority of
moderates
it is absolutely not basically any of
the conservatives very very few
when you look at this several years ago
but the hidden tribes
uh study that came out of data i
actually talked about hidden tribes
eight percent of the us identifies as
progressive yeah yeah they're flying the
flag of a
fringe fringe minority the american flag
represents every american citizen
the pride flag you're allowed to like it
i got no issue but it certainly does not
represent
the 92 percent of the country oh of
course that's the case but they want to
through the politics and the culture to
to transform that and
they they just got a new independence
day you know we're coming up on july 4th
also known as independence day
but now we have a new independence day
it's actually in the name of the bill
the juneteenth national independence day
act this is a local tradition from
galveston when some random dude showed
up and mentioned that lincoln had freed
the slaves years earlier that slaves
actually weren't
legally freed until the 13th amendment
which was ratified months after that
but this random date was contrived
almost out of whole cloth by the left
to become the new national independence
day and the republicans voted for it
well i i take issue if
if the idea is to subvert july 4th yeah
but actually
i i don't take issue with juneteenth uh
i'm i'm down for it
if look we have labor day you know what
i mean like a
yeah holiday commemorating people who
work i guess this is my this is my
problem because i see your point sure
it's a fun you know it's
a good thing to free the slaves so sure
i mean we honor those who shed blood
a lot of blood and treasure
grant said blood and treasure was shed
to to to you know together and to end
this we already have a holiday for that
that is memorial day was set up after
the assassination of lincoln
specifically to honor the dead of the
civil war and all that that were
represented
i've noticed with you mentioned labor
day all of our holidays
they have to do with gratitude all of
them labor day it's the ordinary
american worker veterans day obviously
memorial day christmas
even new year's day we sing about old
lang zine you know we'll have a cup of
kindness yet
what about fourth of july fourth of july
obviously is uh
gratitude to our our country and our
founding fathers and the country they
gave us
but juneteenth i find it bereft of
gratitude you hear it in the arguments
during the debate to ratify
juneteenth all of these congressmen
saying this is about the injustice
to never forget the evils of this
country and even barack obama
when he started mentioning juneteenth
and he said last year
that juneteenth is not about a victory
juneteenth is about the ever long march
toward progress i think that's by the
way why they just picked this random
event when some dude showed up in texas
it's it's not commemorating anything
real it's just commemorating a middle
period
in between two other events because it's
not about the victory
it's to remind you of the evils we've
come from and how far
we have would go but maybe they just
shouldn't frame it that way
maybe it should be framed as a it was
the with the marshall showed up in
galveston where some texans were holding
uh slaves long after the emancipation
proclamation and these were the last
individuals
to to finally receive their freedom but
they still but it still wasn't
properly abolished until the 13th event
i recognize
that um i i like the idea of more
freedom the better you know what i mean
yeah i just i'll tell you i'll tell you
my issue with it is they attached
the red salute to it now that is a very
serious problem not just the red so it
was the red salute
in in black so it was also the the black
nationalist hand
and also as and i couldn't tell this on
twitter but i think it colors
yeah where the knuckles gay i think they
had something no no no no no no it was
uh um
it was red green and white i think oh
the sort of black nationalist
you know the italians always have a
racial middle ground anyway yeah
i i i like the idea of uh of
celebrating you know the end of slavery
yeah
we all do it desperately needs a
branding makeover
but it wasn't i mean but but but look at
it this way abolitionist or something
no i i think it's fine i think it's i
think it's fine
holiday named after a day or a month
it's so weird it's also there
or is it june 13th 14th yeah 18th it's
very confusing
i i i i'm not worried about that i'm
worried about
the critical race theorists are they
hate everything
but they're like juneteenth no no as you
mentioned it was not a day of
celebration or gratitude it was
commemorate our anger i'm like yeah yeah
i'm not about that i think it should be
a day to celebrate our victory over
you know the amoral horrifying
institution of slavery but we
we agree on that i guess my own this
kind of gets back to what we were saying
earlier about
arguing about what the government should
be in theory or what and
what it is in practice i agree with you
there could be a wonderful day to
celebrate the end of slavery and
sort of memorial day is that though we
don't really think of it that way
anymore
but the fact is the people who pushed
for juneteenth
and wrote the name of the bill and made
the debates for it and are celebrating
it and putting the blackfist with the
either gay or black power colors on the
knuckles
all of those guys view it and are
presenting it as this resent filled
anti-american day of reckoning and i
think
yes would that we could perceive it
another way but i i just don't know
you're right about memorial day there
was a um i
i i didn't look at the story too much
but uh someone's mica got cut off he was
like a veteran
because he mentioned memorial day was
set up because of the civil war and had
to do with slavery
and then they were like no no we don't
want to have this he's out yeah but
but it was true memorial day was was was
set up uh following
what you said was the after the
assassination of lincoln yeah i mean
very very shortly there so i i i do
think it's it's important to
um man this is this is tough right it's
uh as i often describe
it great how many grains of sand make a
heap it might not be a big deal to many
people they're like juneteenth it's a
great holiday it celebrates the end of
slavery
and then you mentioned memorial day does
that yeah and and those who shed blood
to end it
so real quick it's not that
any one of one of these arguments
debates or news stories
is the most important but when you stack
up ten thousand of them
you've now have a dramatic shift in your
culture and ultimately
how people live their freedoms this is
how things are better or worse it's
death by a thousand cuts right or all
the sand
but because i i agree with all the
people who are shrugging their shoulders
and saying oh man who cares i don't
you know it's no another day off frankly
it's not a day off for us right it's a
day off for some federal employees but
okay
fine they they work so hard don't they
yeah but
the the who cares argument has a simple
answer
the left cares that's why they fought
tooth and nail to get this thing through
it's the same as the pronouns who cares
about the pronouns i wouldn't care about
the pronouns
except that the left really cares about
the pronouns because they know
that in these very seemingly trivial
things
you carry whole premises in the case of
the pronouns you carry the premise
that human nature has nothing to do with
our body and a man can be a woman in the
case of juneteenth you carry the premise
that the original independence day was a
fraud it was it was wicked
and we and the country is now in
juneteenth the country is evil and we
need to reckon with it did you see there
was one jurisdiction that canceled their
july 4th parade over kovid
but they're having a g they had a
juneteenth celebration of course of
course i mean
the fourth of july parade that's
unnecessary and frankly it's even worse
than unnecessary but juneteenth
that's our nation's most sacred feast
let's go to super chat i
had a question real quick can i identify
as no gender yes yes okay i'm going to
start doing it
yeah and you you get an x on your id oh
i don't want it actually i don't
identify it as an ex i want nothing
it's called agender i'm not agender i
just don't have one that's what they do
i'm not an atheist i just don't believe
necessarily believe in anybody without
didn't say gender is the word didn't
prince the musician he was like he just
didn't have a name
that's why they called him the artist
formerly apparently they're like legal
reasons so it's harder to sue him or
something
really i don't know that's what i heard
anyway let's go to super chats
if you have not already smash that like
button subscribe to this channel
share this show and make sure you go to
timcast.com become a member support our
fierce and independent journalism
and the bonus segment which will be
coming up after the show all right john
lee says tim i had some questions
are you going to put the stream on your
website and where is my chicken stream
it's been a month since i asked
we are rebuilding chicken city to make
it bigger and better
and improved and um we're doing a lot of
work right now it should be done
maybe early next week and then we've got
to set up
the computers and everything so as we
get more and more people onto the team
like we're hiring like i mentioned the
paranormal rider and stuff like that
then we can hire faster and faster and
faster but it's a snowball rolling down
a hill so it starts slow
chickens are doing their thing um we are
going to be building this really awesome
we're building this really awesome like
external little cabin treehouse to house
the computers and the servers
that will be above or underneath it is
the chicken city
where we'll have the cameras in the
stream this way we can have a protected
area from rain and
and bad weather so the cameras can
always be operating and more
open space uh there's there's some other
logistical reasons why we have to move
it to
in order to make it happen but you know
they've been eating the ground right
they've been basically
chickenizing the earth underneath them
they can't eat the bugs or the
grass are they having like consumed all
the grass and nothing so they need to be
constantly moved around or have a lot
we need a bigger space for the chicken
run it's an analogy of capitalism yeah
it is not sustainable on its own we need
to import food we need to bring things
in so
we they need to have their coop and then
you have the big open field where they
can do
you know chicken stuff cheese stuff yeah
that's right all right let's see
tony l says drop a like for michael
knowles tim pool jam session
yes maybe maybe man super fun mark west
as i didn't know knowles played the
guitar rock on yeah
that's that's a michael knowles original
you can only hear here
tim castaire mad finger picking maddie
met matt says what the heck tim i
thought the jam days were supposed to be
on fridays i'm
speechless wow just like michael
knowles's new book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is now on sale you know if i had
if i had really thought to get my own
plugin
i would have done the jam with no words
oh everything
everybody should buy michael nols's book
so that it hits number one
and then everyone who goes to amazon or
whatever they see it and they go i
wonder what this is and they look at it
and they buy it
and then the new york times they're like
here's a best seller that's what needs
to happen it would be so glorious the
one thing i've noticed
you know i've been perusing the charts
just uh obsessively
and just completely neurotically and
i've been looking apparently the
majority of books in the top 100 books
on amazon
are children's books and cookbooks
interesting they are
but there are some political books up
there
i really look i want to beat the left
but i really want to beat ben shapiro
i really he you know he's got a book
coming out it's called the authoritarian
moment that's going to be my campaign
slogan when i run in a few years guys
knowles 2028 the authoritarian moment
and so i really i
you know all those things please help me
to beat you please
all right we got one here um uh valerian
says 10 10 opening
i was left speechless just like when i
read
unmasked by andy wait wait
good book oh man you got me they got you
got me um how many
of these do i have to read rampton says
michael knowles plays guitar and sings
i'm speechless
speak of speechless speechless
controlling words controlling minds now
available for order i hope i'll sign my
audiobook
i will sign your audiobook bring it on
over oh
man wow is it is that just it's all the
super chats pretty much these are all
these are super chats i'm reading
through that that's great
the whole thing is like every single one
is i'm speechless we just love it no no
i i genuinely mean it i mean one of the
most powerful things you can do
let me explain something um i think
joergen's great with all due respect
i think one of the biggest issue one of
the biggest issues for
him moving off of itunes was that
because he was
first in best address when it comes to
podcasts whenever you'd open
itunes yeah the the podcast app you'd
see joe rogan
by going exclusive to spotify and
getting paid very well for it my view
he lo he lost that real estate so i'm
sure it had an impact to a certain
degree
so uh i bring that up just because being
the top
trending anything yeah on an algorithm
from these big networks
means uh the at the marketing power you
get cannot be paid for
if if speechless becomes number one on
amazon yeah
that's marketing power that creates it's
a snowball rolling down a hill
you get to a certain threshold and then
people who have not heard about it from
this show or any other show start buying
it
and then it dominates but the most
important thing is the cultural impact
it would have
for people to see the top-selling book
is a book like speechless it would and
to unseat one of these lib books or one
shapiro or or more importantly no i
would have to agree with your criticism
of joe rogan only because joe has not
yet invited me on his show
if he invites me i will retract my
criticism in that way yes
i'm not trying to criticize him i'm just
saying but i am because he didn't know
i'm joking yeah they
spot if i bought that bought it out for
him right there we're gonna make sure
yeah yeah yeah
you're worth giving up that spot on
itunes yeah but it's very very powerful
powerful
but like you said money money money
can't buy that kind of that kind of
exposure
i mean you kind of yeah but it can buy
like jets and stuff right and like sh
and boats i guess enough money can buy
you well here's an interesting question
right so one of the reasons i would not
want to give up
something like that is because my goal
is not just about me making money and
buying a house it's like
the way i explain it is i make money
doing this job and the company's doing
really well
i don't want to buy a ferrari i want to
buy a good journalism
yeah yeah i'm i'm i'm happy when we'll
have
a great expose you know that comes out
and exposes corruption i'll be
like yes like it was the work of that
journalist
and it was what i was able to help fund
and pay for
so when i'm sitting on my deathbed and
i'm thinking about the things i have i
will have historical moments
that have done good things that helped
change the world for the better i don't
care about stuff
you know i forget who it was it was some
dead guy i'm just gonna say moliere but
i don't know it could be shaw i could
have no idea what it was
somebody said that that hell the
definition of hell
is the place where you have nothing to
do but amuse yourself and we all know
that's true right
you know even when you're in school and
you go on vacation the first two or
three days just like loafing around
watching movies whatever
and by day four you're you're just
suicidal you know you're like give me
something to do again
and that's what you're saying tim is
like you know tooling around in your
ferrari is great
but eventually you want to do something
yeah
yeah i want to uh i would have more fun
i'll tell you one thing you know what
why i really wanted to hire someone to
do paranormal and unsolved mysteries
is because i was on a road trip i've
been on several road trips i i drove
from
new york to chicago to north dakota for
the dakota access pipeline stuff
and i love unsolved mystery stories yeah
but it's so hard to find a good one
and so i'm like pulling up some ghost
stories and a lot of them are no
disrespect to some of these shows i
won't call up my name
but it's like a guy talking to somebody
it's like a phone call and i'm like
where's the true crime style of like
with music
and stuff but for the paranormally
unexplained
and i couldn't find it i google searched
it and i listened to
dozens or hundreds trying to find like
something that was like the show
unsolved mysteries was i grew up
watching when i was a kid and i was like
always freaked out like i know music
all of our moms had lifetime on i know
you know it's television for women but
they had unsolved mysteries it was good
it was great the the the i've heard the
guy's name who did the voice but his
voice was just so good and the music was
creepy and i was always like sitting
there scared and i'm like i want a show
like that
so i don't need a ferrari i need a show
like that so i'm like who do i fund
so we're working on it that's where we
have this guy he's writing long form
pieces every week exploring some a lot
of these stories cults murders mysteries
ghosts bigfoot etc
and then we're going to turn it into a
podcast once a week where it's a
combination of
story sound effects like a feature plus
discussion and conversation after after
that goes on i love that i mean i get
you know dw is trying to do similar
sorts of things but this is the problem
where
you know i'm bad as conservative as it
gets i'm like knuckle dragging attila
the hun
and and yet friday night rolls around
and me and the honey are sitting on the
couch watching something
and we're all we're watching these you
know they're
they're entertainment pieces but they're
from a lib perspective on lib platforms
i'm giving my money to some lib
billionaire and i think
what why can't we do that why can't we
do something i don't want it to be
political no no no
but i would say that i i think my
perspective is going to be a moral
framework built on uh judeo-christian
values yeah i am not
a particularly religious person but i
grew up with
america having these values so i don't
think we're not going to make a movie
where
it's like um an evil abortion doctor is
going around you know kidnapping women
anything like crazy like that no it'll
be like a regular movie but it'll have
tropes about
heroic behavior yes um uh it'll probably
be stories
right you know stories that chaos and
loss and struggle and
just success and overcoming things about
people in their lives it's not super
political but there will probably just
be that perspective within it that's not
lib perspective that's not leftist or
woke
and that's what you know i think we need
like you know so anyway i think the guy
was robert stack
from unsolved mysteries the narrator
great that was the guy yeah robert
jack i love that guy all right
what does it say blur star blur star
says michael i am an unaligned christian
leaning toward catholic or orthodox i
think the pope being the shepherd to the
church is important
but i have a problem with papal
supremacy what should i do to figure out
my internal conflict
well you should show up to mass i
believe you know if your issue
is the the role of the pope and when we
say
papal supremacy that can mean a very
narrow thing of the special role for the
pontiff and the vicar of christ
or it can mean this ridiculous kind of
broad thing where that
a lot of people misunderstand it to mean
that if the pope says the two plus two
equals five that
it does and that's just it's not what it
means the pope has the right
to and and a special privilege to uh
of infallibility when he is discussing
uh matters of faith and morals
from ex cathedra right this is a narrow
world he has the right to defend
catholic doctrine
he does not have the right to negate
catholic doctrine he can't do that the
pope could come out tomorrow
and say all sorts of kooky things and it
wouldn't carry any weight
going back not just a few hundred years
but going back to the earliest days of
the church
the bishop of rome had a special role in
in figuring out disputes between the
other bishops between alexandria
and athens this comes from peter peter
is the first bishop of rome you can
trace that
unbroken line all the way down the keys
are handed to peter and christ says
christ says you are peter and on this
rock i will build my church and the
gates of hell shall not prevail against
it
and he says the who sins you forgive are
forgiven who sins you retain or retained
i give you the keys to the kingdom of
heaven that seems to be a special
privilege
and peter ends his life or his life is
ended for him
crucified upside down in rome and and
the obelisk that was looking upon that
very
cruci uh crucified peter is now standing
in
in vatican city and and so i think
a lot of times you'll hear people make
anti-catholic arguments by going back to
the alleged history and they all say
there are all these various apostasies
and everything
i think the history is on the side of
rome
right on all right mr toad says michael
i just bought your first book as i
eagerly await the arrival of the new one
i don't have time to read it though
because i drive all day for a living is
there an audiobook
audiobook version available for reasons
to vote for democrats there is in fact
there is you can look up the artist is
john cage
the uh the title is 433
this is the official audiobook of
reasons to vote for democrats and i hope
you enjoy it
is he just turning pages yeah it's a
beautiful musical composition
this uh this super chat's actually from
a while ago tyler toth says fix your
shirt collar knoll shaking my head is it
popping out no no
no no you know you know
no i'm actually i'm glad to hear this
because
sometimes people worry i'm a little too
buttoned up okay i usually lose my
i'm getting a loose baby i thought it
was intentional i'm at tim poole's show
all right
how about one column
all right let's see douglas kaplan says
tim michael i pray that your businesses
grow i want the truth and sometimes the
truth is in the middle
i really hope this donation helps out it
certainly does thank you very much
oh thank you that's very nice thank you
caleb greenlee says hey michael please
state why you think a liberal education
is important
also what do y'all think of joining the
military with the outbreak of wokeness
in the military
poli-sci major and naval officer
applicant so the purpose of a liberal
education is to make sense of your
freedom that's what it that's what it
comes from
the liberal arts we are free people
because we're human beings
uh however we have lower wills and
higher wills and the higher
rational will the lower will is our
appetite it's
it's we want to shoot up the heroine or
we want to eat too much fast food or we
want to write
we want to see too many women and then
the higher will is the rational will
we know we shouldn't do some of those
things but if we don't cultivate virtue
and discipline our will and develop
those habits
we give in to them anyway saint paul
writes about this he says the things
that i want to do
i do not do the things that i don't want
to do i do that sounds like a
an impossibility but of course he's
referring to these two wills
and this lower will which is our
appetite hopefully will come into
the discipline of the higher will that's
what happens in liberal education and
the higher will is the mediator between
the lower will and the divine will
okay that's the theory of it uh the way
this is practiced is by
by learning these liberal arts the
problem is that it's very difficult to
get a liberal education today
at the great schools what are considered
the most prestigious schools it's almost
impossible
donald kagan the great ancient greek
historian former dean of yale college
he once commented that you did not need
a liberal education to graduate from
yale he later commented you might not be
able to get a liberal education if you
graduate from yale
i think there are a handful of schools
where you can get it hillsdale ave maria
franciscan of steubenville thomas
aquinas
a handful but if you don't get it there
i would strongly recommend you do it
yourself you you uh
engage in the great reading lists my
friend spencer clavin has a great
podcast on this
young heretics which takes you through
the western canon it's really important
i know you know conservatives very often
they'll say just major in stem just
major in engineering that's the only
thing
i think totally the opposite if you're
going to study anything study
literature study history study
philosophy
it's not going to get you a job but it
will help you make sense of your freedom
and you can go to trade school after
that
right on and trade school's probably
better for work anyway it's way better
for work yeah
ben walker says glad to see my favorite
austere religious podcaster back on the
show thank you it's good to be back
it's good to be with you oh yeah and i
want to mention too because he asked
about joining the military my opinion on
the military as someone who hasn't
served is just
i've talked to a lot of people who said
that they ended their careers over the
what was in the military
yeah no i i have as well very very sad
to see but i think that's the
culmination of the strategy right they
yeah the woke people want them to end
their theirs and then
russia fires some morning shots and
china takes taiwan and we go
well we shouldn't retaliate against
china because of
white privilege and collapsing kind of
started it actually and
taiwan's probably better with them
anyway but russia has a bunch of white
dudes
yeah so we can go to war with them but
you know russia they're the only white
dudes who are allowed to be
rather they're the villainous white
dudes like you know in the movies
uh black guys and and other races can
never be the villain
almost never there but there's all so
it's a white villain and the villain is
always the russian
yeah because they're like kind of the
weird white it was british for a while
now it's russia
they love those two rad number two says
tim if you ever get big enough to start
a movie studio
please make a realistic remake of red
dawn where the bad guys are the woke
u.s military all i ask and return to
this idea is a producer credit
uh that doesn't sound too expensive to
produce at all no you know so
the guy who made the original red dawn
is actually a friend of mine john
millius
this legend in hollywood he's lebowski
is based on him
he's just this lovely maniac you know
he's got guns everywhere he's a cigar
chomp and you know he yeah he said he
you really i mean he's tremendous and
his daughter amanda milius is a
filmmaker
who did yes she did the plot against the
president i would absolutely love
to do a movie where there is a rift
in uh us armed forces between woke and
anti-woke
i would not want to make a movie where
we villainize one or the other right
where like the woke are like
but we actually represent their ideas as
they stand and then show this conflict
between two factions in the us breaking
apart
and do an actual i mean i wonder if it
would be like
there's no real antagonist or it's it's
kind of like well the red dawn is from
within
right it's just it's like our own guys
you know in in most movies there's a
very clear antagonist protagonist or the
k
you you know who the good guys the bad
guys are i think it'd be interesting to
have
you know there are movies that have done
this kind of thing where you have just
the perspective of the two factions and
the war they engage in without saying
either is good or bad so you're saying
you could have two conservative and the
lib go to watch the movie and they each
think the other one is the
antagonist yeah or or actually be like
get mad yeah and be like that's not how
we think
yeah and the conservative would say the
same thing in the liberals say the same
thing but
it would actually try to be a fair
representation of of the values
not as they see it as it is right right
you know what i mean
yeah so you might actually end up with a
conservative arguing that we have to
curtail some civil liberties it's like
war time like abraham lincoln like in
world war ii
with all due respect to the bill of
rights this is war
and we suspend habeas corpus when it
comes to fighting for our lives and our
values
and then you have the woke saying the
exact same thing in a different way you
know the founding fathers were bad
and if we don't use any means necessary
to win we will be wiped out by white
supremacists well i think it was john
mccain who made this point you know john
mccain was very anti-torture because he
was tortured in vietnam
and but i i don't think this is
apocryphal i think i'm remembering this
clearly
john mccain was asked well what if what
if there were a really bad event about
to happen would you torture someone he
says no
well what if it were really really bad
would you torture someone no what if
some guy's about to set off a bomb in
downtown l.a and the only way to get the
codes is to torture him
and he finally says well i'd get the
codes right you know
at a certain point we're all gonna do
what has to be done
yeah there's a good one clef the misfit
says tim for your crossfire thing with
vosh you need to put him against eric
july
he said you wanted a libertarian and it
will keep vosh from using racialized
arguments as a defense mechanism
actually i think eric julie would be
fantastic not necessarily because i
think
it would keep washroom using racialized
arguments i think he would and
certainly if that's his position he
should i just think eric july actually
would be a really
great person to have on with with wash
so eric if you're hearing this let's uh
let's let's see if you you know maybe we
can have
yeah what do you think yeah i think
that's a good idea in fact both of the
other people that i recommended to argue
were african-american so i think that's
a great idea yeah
i'm not trying to do you know this this
partly came out on twitter because uh
he mentioned that he's spoken with a ton
of conservatives and none of them knew
what critical race theory was
and to be fair i think my response to
him was not
i could have done a better job the the
issue with it you know when he asked me
to define critical race theory i was
like
in layman's terms i can't give you the
academic academic definition i don't
have it pulled up
but what i was trying to convey was
because i don't prepare for debates like
i'm trying to go to the war with this
guy
there are things that people say about
critical race theory
let's try and break down what that means
and what our actual complaints are
authoritarianism
racial identitarianism these things and
an overt attack on property rights i
mean one i forget the guy who wrote it
but it's in that seminal text on
critical race theory
they say that the the very system of
private property in the united states
is a white supremacist evil system that
needs to be dismantled that's why people
call them communists is because
they are but so um you know i wasn't
approaching it like
i needed to prove to his side i knew
what i was talking about yeah so i'm
like but anyway this would end up coming
about i was like
i'd love to have you back on the show we
get another conversation and maybe see
where our views have changed or
elaborate or developed and things like
that and my issue is
if you want me to say critical race
theory is the analysis of where race
intersects with policy
sure but that's not what anyone means by
critical race theory right
that's that's the that's the elevator
pitch they give you when when academics
ask what it is
it's not fair and it's not true that's
important to flesh out the definitions
like lydia you like you were saying
earlier it's the
impetus of debate is that you know the
definition of what you're debating yeah
how else can you at least you know the
other person's idea of what the
definition is
all right let's see what uh what we got
evan says michael did you get my
christmas wreath
last year i didn't get my thank you note
oh you did you know i actually i thought
i did send you a thank you note but i'm
very sorry if
if that did not go out and i promise to
fire however many assistants that i need
to for not sending it out
i loved it you know wow i'm so glad that
you're here i got this wonderful
christmas wreath now two years in a row
with a lovely advent uh like a you know
a candle holder
and it's great i put it up right in my
living room and i put the wreath on my
on my front door
advent calendars are the best oh i love
it oh yeah you're telling me
so you know it's during advent in the
month of december
you every day you're supposed to open it
up and read some scripture and really
meditate on on the coming of christ and
then when you're kids it's really you
just kind of get like a chocolate every
single day
they have them for adults now though
which is it'll have like a little nip in
it you know
some kind of booze and they're like you
know usually you open them right in the
morning so it's like i don't know if i
need an eye opener as i'm
waiting when i was little we had this
cloth calendar where a little mouse
would move from day to day
tracking the days and we had the advent
calendars you'd pop open the day and
there's a scripture and then you get a
piece of candy yeah yeah
oh man those are the days all right
let's see
um jyn says michael i have re received
your new book speechless controlling
words controlling minds today i'm on
chapter three and very much enjoying it
so far thank you for your work
thank you very much i'm so honored when
people read it you know especially
i've i've come to this as a best-selling
author of nothing
right so i the only thing i've ever
published is nothing and then people
joking this out read your book uh-huh
you know i read it very quickly and it's
funny i mean i made the jokes too
but yeah i'm i'm actually really quite
uh happy that people are reading it and
i i'm glad that you don't hate it i'm
glad that you like it
yeah all right we'll do uh we'll try and
get as many more as we can
in jesus lopez or jesus lopez yeah
did anyone know native americans kept
slaves three years after america
declared them free
yeah is that true i did know that and
they also uh
the civilized tribes that's i'm i'm not
inventing that term that's actually what
they were referred to
in parts of the united states uh they
held slaves at a similar rate to the
local whites
and a lot of a lot of people don't know
that the native americans who were
marched down the trail of tears
actually shipped slaves in front of them
and in some cases marched the slaves in
front of them as well and they
they were not as eager to give up their
slaves as other people in the country
you're not allowed to tell that story
though because it messes up the
victim narrative of of the left that is
very interesting interesting
all right let's see actual justice
warrior says juneteenth is called
emancipation day in texas oh cool it was
called black
independence day on the show blackish
check google almost no mentions pre-2017
yeah no it's com it's completely made up
and we i mean it's not made up in the
sense it was a local tradition
as a national fact it's completely made
up and uh
the thing that i find so offensive about
it is not that the left contrived
this fake holiday to reframe american
history it's that they
forced us all to pretend like we'd ever
heard of this thing before
no statistically very few people had
ever heard of juneteenth before like
three years ago yeah well the argument
from the left is why didn't we why
didn't we
but the weird thing is when i when i
went to school when i was growing up
they're like i see this meme from the
left they're like why didn't you know
about the the tulsa massacre
of black wall street and i was like i
did i do yeah we'll write that for
the tulsa race riot sure you know but i
even i even think an answer to that
question why had you not heard of
juneteenth
like because it didn't matter that much
is actually my answer not important well
this is the interesting thing i was
having
an argument with someone and i think it
was on twitter i don't know maybe it
wasn't on twitter but oh no it was on
facebook
and they were like they don't teach this
stuff and i was like they taught it
where i grew up yeah
and we all knew about this stuff yeah
and they're like well they didn't teach
it to me and i was like
did you grow up in a wealthy suburb well
yeah i was like
maybe no no but for real you grew up in
a white suburb yeah where they probably
didn't think it was relevant for you so
you're shocked
i grew up in the south side of chicago
where they probably thought it was
relevant because of
it's chicago it's extremely racially
diverse it's segregated but it probably
was
you know something that people knew
about of course i grew up in new york we
learned a lot about the iroquois why
because the iroquois were the indians
from new york
i didn't learn that much about the
cherokee or the apache i bet i bet
people who lived in those areas of the
country learn more about them of course
our communities actually have something
to do with our education in northeast
ohio we talked a lot about the iroquois
the longhouses and stuff
yeah third grade we used to learn about
them they were cannibals actually people
that's another thing you're not allowed
a lot of those natives were cannibals
yeah the caribs actually the word
cannibal comes from the carob islanders
who who were uh famously cannibals
columbus discovered
reza aslan is a famous
you find them in the iroquois in the
caribbean and on cnn yeah
you will too well they canceled this
show um
la says hey tim are you hiring data
analysts at the moment if so where do we
apply i'm pretty skilled artist as well
thanks keep it the good work
hopefully soon but i don't think right
now um
maybe in a few months it just depends on
where we where we go and grow
the newsroom is an investment there's
there's no guarantee that we make money
off of a newsroom
but i want a newsroom so like i said i'm
not gonna buy a ferrari i'm gonna buy a
newsroom and we're gonna have
journalists do awesome stuff
but hopefully the articles will be
relevant we'll be trustworthy i believe
they will
be hiring a fact check an editor and a
fact checker so it's like triple checked
the the journalist does the work the
editor reviews it and the fact checker
goes back through it and the
fact-checker won't even be in the same
building as these people
as the journalists and then hopefully
that that value proposition of
getting double fact check and good
reporting
makes people share it they read it and
then it just it serves as a way to
have people find out about the website
and then it helps grow the business
effectively marketing
journalism was always a loss leader it
was prestigious
people wanted to know about the news but
then they would get access to the other
bits of the newspaper the advertisements
or whatever so
journalism was always a way to like
spread the word to spread the word about
what you the work you're doing
and the news hopefully this works out
we'll see how it plays out but i think
either way
we are going to be subsidizing good
journalism as long as
i'm alive and well you know we'll figure
out how to make it last beyond that
that's kind of the point
oh hey this is cool someone just said
where'd it go just jumped away from me
sam smith says speeches is number one in
politics and propaganda
because they can't accept that as a
number one in hearts and minds
wow thank you and i take it as a great
honor to be considered the number one
propagandist
in america congratulations speaking of
cnn yeah i'm glad i supplanted this is
that actually a category though
propaganda i take it that it is i mean
you know
on amazon there's a million different
categories but yeah i'm glad they're
they're already calling me a
propagandist all right jonathan dugger
says michael i had a calling to take
matthew 10 38 literally i have to make
12
i have to make 12 feet tall by 6 feet
wide and carry it to my church which is
10 miles away from my house
any helpful advice would be appreciated
hmm could you pull up the ver i'm sorry
that the verse is not jumping to my mind
matthew 10 38 yeah do you have it i yeah
i can look it up hold on
look it up while she pulls it up i'll
read this stephen walker says get actual
justice warrior on the show tim
i have heard good things i have heard
good things yeah
um sure this you know this is that proof
the protestants always knock the
catholics because we don't read the
bible now we do
we read the bible liturgically we read
it as part of meth but it means that we
can't like we don't
pull these up all of the time the one
verse i can always pull up is leviticus
17
7. ye shall no longer sacrifice your
sacrifices to goat demons after whom you
[ __ ]
huh wow that's a pretty solid everyone's
stuck out sacrifices
like not sacrifice yeah yeah sorry no no
we'll go later
the verse uh that he was talking about
which makes sense um matthew 10 38 says
whoever does not take up their cross and
follow me is not worthy of you
so he wants to like physically build a
cross and haul around yes well it's very
i mean that's
uh not everything is to be taken quite
literally you know
the parables for instance are not are
not literal but that it is important
that people take up their cross and
don't forget by the way people always
think well you got to take up your cross
and it's just going to be awful and
terrible
but christ also says my yoke is easy and
my burden is light there's some this is
actually quite a sanctifying process
maybe you can build the cross out of
balsa wood
well what is it jordan peterson says
about picking up the heaviest thing you
can find and carrying it that's the same
idea
yeah that's true and the lobsters and a
lot of the other things that always
sticks out yeah
ladies and gentlemen thanks for hanging
out it's been fun make sure you smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share with your friends give us
a good review on itunes spotify all that
stuff become a member
at timcast.com because we have a bonus
segment coming up usually it was around
11 p.m
the other day with ben it went really
long so it ended up going like later but
i thought it was a really fantastic
segment where we talked about a lot
about all the things youtube doesn't
allow us to talk about i'll also add one
quick point or actually i'll say
follow follow follow the show at timcast
irl on facebook and instagram
help share our videos and like them so
that we can attract more people to the
website which will stand
independently and we're trying to
leverage these networks you can follow
me personally at tim cast
someone super chatted saying that i
should go to wakefield skatepark
uh i will do my best to be there on
saturday oh is it nearby
um it's like it's it's maybe 50 60 miles
oh okay so it's a dry but um
what do we do maybe saturday uh maybe
saturday morning
we'll uh we'll we'll be there man
actually i don't know if i can do
saturday morning
we'll see i'll try to get there we'll
see if i'm there um you want to shout
out a book perhaps
oh oh this whole thing are you this is
you have a new book
you know i'm glad to be here on the
official distribution channel of
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
probably more than the daily wire even
at this point that's legally binding you
said it is oh no
this is your book now i did i brought it
thank you so much to everyone who's
pre-ordered speechless controlling words
controlling minds available i think
there's still some signed first editions
uh which you can get at
speechlessbook.com you can also get it
anywhere books are sold
including in the top propaganda bin at
amazon
in the in the in the gas station
propaganda bin
the propaganda bin at the airport yes uh
follow median crossland.net and
on social media ian crossland i just
want to give a special shout out to
michael knowles new book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
pick up a copy on uh on amazon yeah and
anywhere that books are sold
is that that's right yes it's perfect i
think that we are in fact selling this
because i did pull up the amazon listing
you are the number one best seller in
quote propaganda and political
psychology i love it
and i didn't have a question michael had
a question for you so your first book
had
no words so to me is that why your
second book is named
speechless it's a little cheeky and by
the way the first book had no words this
book is
about words the entire book is about
words yes and so i feel like i've
covered the entire spectrum i agree and
i never have to do it again
yes awesome i have a i have a book that
says like um
it's something like the uh how the
policies of the left will save america
and then every page just says they won't
they won't
i was gonna try to sue the guy you know
i didn't know because there are other
blank books
yeah there's everything men know about
women sex after 50 the written wisdom of
the german people they're a bunch
that should be mine all right everybody
we will see you over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you